Now I can do anything.
I like my friends.
I like my podcast.
I like my Jason.
I like my Sean.
I like my smartless.
I like everybody.
Let's go.
现在我能做任何事了。我喜欢我的朋友们。我喜欢我的播客。我喜欢我的杰森。我喜欢我的肖恩。我喜欢我的《聪明无知》。我喜欢每一个人。我们开始吧。
It's an all new smart list.
First of all, though, I would just like to say really fast,
have birthday to you.
Oh, Will, happy birthday.
Oh, Will, or not.
Happy birthday to you.
And it's on.
May the fourth be with you.
这是一个全新的《聪明无知》。不过首先，我想非常迅速地对大家说，祝你生日快乐。哦，威尔，生日快乐。哦，威尔，或者没有。祝你生日快乐。而且就在今天。“愿原力与你同在”。
I know, which is one of my biggest.
regrets that somebody came up with that.
I love, are you kidding?
It's first I've heard of it.
No, because it's just, it's just completely
you know, taking my birthday hostage forever.
Not for me.
It's, you're lucky you're not born on the,
我知道，这是我最后悔的事之一，居然有人想出了这个梗。我喜欢，你在开玩笑吗？这是我第一次听说。不，因为这完全是，你知道的，把我的生日永远扣为人质了。对我来说不是。你很幸运，你没有出生在……
on 420, right?
Isn't that the, with all the kids
like to smoke their weed on the 420?
Hey man, I've been looking for ways for you
to sound older.
Yeah.
And I think we just found it.
You know what I mean?
在四月二十日，对吧？那是不是所有孩子们都喜欢在四月二十日抽大麻的日子？嘿，伙计，我一直在寻找能让你听起来更老的方法。对。而且我想我们刚刚找到了。你知道我的意思吗？
How about this?
Does this down?
How about...
But Jason, for you and me,
it's also, more importantly, it's Cinco de Quatro.
Cinco de Quatro, a very big day in the people that know about arrested.
In the arrest development canon, Sean, so thank you.
Sean, thank you for following the show.
这个怎么样？这个听起来……怎么样……但是杰森，对你我来说，更重要的是，这也是“五月四日节”（Cinco de Quatro）。“五月四日节”，对于知道《发展受阻》的人来说是一个非常重大的日子。在《发展受阻》的剧集背景里，肖恩，所以谢谢你。肖恩，谢谢你一直关注这部剧。
Speaking of Sean, let's take a moment to celebrate Sean's Tony Award nomination.
I know.
Don't wave it away.
It's a big deal.
Thank you.
And very well deserved.
Good Lord, is that show good.
Again, just to repeat, anybody going through the tri-state area, stop in New York City.
说到肖恩，让我们花点时间庆祝一下肖恩获得托尼奖提名。我知道。别把它挥手推开。这可是件大事。谢谢。而且实至名归。我的天哪，那部剧太棒了。再次重申，任何经过三州地区的人，都在纽约市停留一下。
It's a fun town, and there's a great show.
What's the theater?
Good Night Oscar at the Belasco Theater.
Some people call it Tabasco, but that's just so they can remember it.
Jason, do you know what the Tony Awards are short for?
Do you know what the actual name of the award is?
Anthony's?
Close.
这是一个有趣的城市，而且有一场很棒的演出。剧院叫什么？在贝拉斯科剧院（Belasco Theater）上演的《晚安，奥斯卡》（Good Night Oscar）。有些人叫它“塔巴斯科”（Tabasco），但那只是为了好记住它。杰森，你知道托尼奖是哪个词的简称吗？你知道这个奖项的真正名字是什么吗？安东尼的？接近了。
No.
Sean, you know, right?
Antoinette.
Antoinette Perry Award.
Really?
Yeah.
And, you know, listener, are you shocked as me
不。肖恩，你知道的，对吧？安托瓦内特。安托瓦内特·佩里奖。真的吗？对。对。而且，你知道，听众朋友们，你和我一样震惊吗？
how smart will every once in a while is?
I am.
He'd also be shocked to know these actually 67 today.
And he looks fantastic.
He does have, you do have like an endless well
of just knowledge and stuff.
I got a lot of time.
I got a lot of time on my hands.
威尔偶尔展现出的博学多才？我很震惊。如果知道他实际上已经六十七岁了，你也会大吃一惊的。而且他看起来棒极了。他的确，你确实拥有源源不断的知识和各种储备。我有很多时间。我手头有很多时间。
Clearly.
Jason, I said to Jason yesterday,
I said, hey, do you want to read this thing that I just wrote?
And he said, please don't. Please don't.
No, he said, oh, I'm going to send you that script.
I said, please don't.
He says, what do you mean?
I go, I don't, I don't even read my own texts.
显然是的。杰森，我昨天对杰森说，我说，嘿，你想读一下我刚写的东西吗？他说，请不要。请不要。不，他说，哦，我要把那个剧本发给你。我说，请不要。他说，你这话什么意思？我说，我才不，我甚至不读我自己的短信。
He's like, well, thank you for your honesty.
I just thought, you know, it's just a fun script.
I said, there's nothing fun about reading.
He did say that.
Yeah, my parents really screwed me.
Now, I'm watching Sean there, itch his eye.
Sean just had, what we call it, ocular surgery?
Laser surgery.
他就像是，好吧，谢谢你的诚实。我只是觉得，你知道的，这只是一个有趣的剧本。我说，阅读一点都不有趣。他确实这么说了。对，我父母真的把我给坑惨了。现在，我看着肖恩在那儿，挠他的眼睛。肖恩刚刚做了，我们称之为，眼部手术？激光手术。
We don't call it that, but he had a...
And I can't read.
I'm not supposed to read.
He's not supposed to read.
And I said, Sean turned to the doctor and said,
you can't read and Sean said,
boy, do I have some good news for you.
But he does have a detached retina.
我们不这么叫它，但他做了个……而且我不能阅读。我不应该阅读。他是不应该阅读的。然后我对肖恩说，你转向医生说，你不能阅读，肖恩说，天哪，我可有个好消息要告诉你。但他确实有视网膜脱落。
So Sean's got a partially detached retina.
Jason's got a detached personality.
So we have, hey, hey, oh.
Detachless.
But Sean, you're still doing seven shows this week
after laser surge.
Yeah, my eye.
I'm not supposed to read or dart my eye around a lot.
所以肖恩的视网膜部分脱落了。杰森的人格脱落了。所以我们有，嘿，嘿，哦。无脱落者。但是肖恩，你这周做完激光手术还要演七场秀？对，我的眼睛。我不应该阅读或者让我的眼睛到处乱转。
That was the direction from the direction.
or from the doctor said,
don't dart your eyes?
Wait, that was his note from the director and the doctor.
And I said to both of you guys,
I'm slowly turning into my mother, I'm going to lose my eye.
I mean, you better knock on wood.
Now, your mom lost your eye from cancer, you said,
那是导演给的指导。或者医生说，不要让你的眼睛到处乱转？等等，那是导演和医生的共同叮嘱。我对你们两个说，我正在慢慢变成我母亲，我会失去一只眼睛。我的意思是，你最好敲敲木头。现在，你说你妈妈是因为癌症失去了一只眼睛，
not from a detached retina thing?
She was two years old.
Yeah.
Oh, she was two years old?
She was two years old when she lost her eye.
Oh, my goodness.
Yeah, we're still looking for it.
So wait, and so I went in and I get Vaso-Vagal.
不是因为视网膜脱落之类的事情？她当时两岁。对。哦，她当时两岁？她失去眼睛的时候才两岁。哦，天哪。对，我们现在还在找呢。所以等等，然后我去了，我得了迷走神经性昏厥。
Do you guys get that?
Excuse me.
Hey, man, we're trying to keep it clean over here, dude.
What do you?
It's when you get nauseous and faint from like, you know, needles or poking at your eyeball.
That happened to me once.
Oh, I get it all the time.
Happen me once.
你们得过这个吗？打扰一下。嘿，伙计，我们在这儿尽量保持节目纯洁呢，老兄。你懂什么？就是当你看到针头或者有人戳你的眼球时，会恶心并晕倒。我以前发生过一次。哦，我经常这样。我发生过一次。
So you just go out if you get nervous about it.
I am like, I have to lay down.
I need a fan.
I need coolness.
I'm going to throw up.
I'm going to shit my hand.
We all feel better with a fan around.
Let's be honest.
所以如果你对此感到紧张，你就会直接昏过去。我简直是，我得躺下。我需要一台风扇。我需要凉爽。我要吐了。我要拉在手上了。老实说，有风扇在身边，我们都会觉得好受些。
What about doing the show?
Do you ever feel it coming on just with nerves for the show?
No, no, that's different.
This is all doctor-health-related stuff.
I passed out getting contact lenses once.
I passed out like...
I tried like 10 years ago to get Botox and I passed out.
But you're trying to get...
那演出的时候呢？你有没有因为演出前的紧张而感到这种症状要发作？没有，没有，那不一样。这纯粹是医生和健康相关的事情。我以前因为戴隐形眼镜晕倒过。我曾经晕倒过……我大概十年前尝试过去打肉毒杆菌，然后我晕倒了。但你试图去……
In fairness, you were trying to get it directly from the cow, right?
In a second.
Sean, what have been amazing is if you passed out going in for Botox
and you fell and cut yourself and then you had to get stitches
and then you passed out while trying to get stitches
from the passing out of getting your Botts.
I do, I get it so bad.
You guys don't get that?
公平地说，你当时是想直接从奶牛身上提取，对吧？等一下。肖恩，最神奇的是，如果你在去打肉毒杆菌的路上晕倒了，然后你摔倒并割伤了自己，接着你不得不去缝针，然后你在试图缝合因为打肉毒杆菌晕倒而造成的伤口时又晕倒了。我是真的，我反应太严重了。你们不会这样吗？
No, man.
It just occurred to me.
We're doing a full talk show.
We do a talk show.
And right now we're doing the Regis and Kathy Lee patter beforehand, right?
What are you talking about?
Well, I used to watch that show, and I'm like, how do they come up with this stuff?
Regis just comes in with his coffee, talks about his weekend, and it covers as full national entertainment for 20 minutes.
没有，老兄。我刚刚突然意识到。我们在做一个完整的脱口秀节目。我们做的是脱口秀。而现在我们在做雷吉斯和凯茜·李（Regis and Kathy Lee）式的寒暄，对吧？你在说什么？嗯，我以前看那个节目，我在想，他们是怎么想出这些玩意的？雷吉斯拿着他的咖啡走进来，聊聊他的周末，这就成了长达二十分钟的全国娱乐节目。
I could talk about 9,000 things for an hour.
I don't think people are interested, right?
I mean, what are we doing here?
What Jason is what Jason is trying to say is he's not interested in your life.
I'm not interested in myself.
He's not interested in himself.
Let's get to somebody who's interesting.
We are going to get somebody interesting, but I do want to say Jason was so grumpy.
我可以就九千个话题聊上一小时。我觉得大家可能不感兴趣，对吧？我的意思是，我们在这儿干嘛呢？杰森的意思是，他对你的生活不感兴趣。我对我自己都不感兴趣。他对自个儿都不感兴趣。咱们找个有意思的人吧。我们会找个有趣的人的，但我确实想说，杰森昨天太暴躁了。
yesterday.
Oh my God.
I was embarrassed.
Jason and I played golf the last three days.
And then yesterday,
none of us played particularly well.
Tuesday we got to play with football great legend,
Gareth Bale, who is just an absolute.
哦，天哪。我当时觉得很尴尬。杰森和我过去三天都在打高尔夫球。然后昨天，我们俩谁也没打得特别好。周二我们有幸和足球巨星贝尔一起打球，他简直是个绝对的……
Soccer for the Americans.
Yeah.
I mean, just an absolute.
Oh, you had to be like freaking out.
I was, God, he's unreal, right?
Yeah, you were a little nervous.
It was like you were playing with Charlize Theron.
I was so, yeah.
对美国人来说是足球。我的意思是，简直是绝对的。哦，你当时一定快抓狂了吧。我是的，天哪，他不真实，对吧？对，你当时有点紧张。感觉就像是在和查理兹·塞隆一起打球。我当时太，对。
Hey, man.
Wait, how does it come up?
about you guys just play golf with all these people
they just randomly show up?
We host a talk show, bro.
Yeah.
I know, but I'm just saying like, how do you organize that?
Well, we met this guy up at some
嘿，老兄。等等，你们是怎么做到和所有人一起打高尔夫球的？他们就这么随机出现吗？我们主持脱口秀节目呢，兄弟。对。我知道，我的意思是，你们是怎么安排的？嗯，我们在某个名人高尔夫锦标赛上遇到了这家伙。
celeb golf tournament.
And then that's what happens.
Hey, let's play golf.
You know, he's a good guy.
We do.
We swap numbers.
We go like, hey, man, we want to play golf with you,
Gareth Bailey.
然后事情就这么发生了。嘿，我们去打高尔夫吧。你知道，他是个好人。我们就这样。我们交换了电话号码。我们说，嘿，伙计，我们想跟你打高尔夫，加雷斯·贝尔。
So if Charlize wanted to play golf,
you would let her play golf, you would let her play.
I don't know.
I'm not answering this.
Listen, I'm now, I'm now pleading the fifth.
So anyway, I was a real
movie.
So he was a grump.
所以如果查理兹想打高尔夫，你会让她打高尔夫，你会让她打的。我不知道。我不回答这个问题。听着，我现在，我现在要行使第五修正案拒证权。所以不管怎样，我当时真是一部电影。所以他是个暴脾气。
He sped out of the parking lot
And to the point that 30 seconds after he left out to call him and go,
Hey man, are you okay?
Why, why?
He did call me as I was getting out of the parking lot.
I was like, oh, no, maybe I pissed him off
because I didn't really say goodbye to anybody.
I just had to get out of there before I embarrassed myself
他猛踩油门冲出了停车场，以至于在他离开三十秒后，我不得不打电话给他，说：“嘿，伙计，你还好吗？”为什么？为什么？他在我开出停车场时确实打电话给我了。我当时想，哦，不，也许我惹毛他了，因为我没有真正和任何人道别。我只是必须赶快离开那里，免得自己出丑，
by like going into some sort of
I played a bad golf round rage.
No, but here's what happened.
Here's what happened.
He went like this.
I was putting my stuff in the back of my car
and his window was open.
And then as he's putting it up and his car,
比如陷入某种因为打了一场糟糕的高尔夫而大发雷霆的状态。不，但事情是这样的。事情是这样的。他是这样的。我当时正在把东西放进车后备厢，他的车窗是开着的。然后当他在车里把车窗升起来的时候，
he's now in drive.
He looks over.
I'm not exaggerating.
It goes like this.
I will.
Zip up the window and pull out.
And I was like,
all because you played a bad game?
他现在挂了前进档。他转过头来。我没有夸张。它是这样的。我，拉上车窗，然后开走了。当时我想，就因为你打了一场烂球？
Yeah, I just, I play too much to play that badly.
And I just need to be more disciplined
and I need to actually really,
if I'm going to be upset about not playing well,
I need to have a reason.
In other words, I need to start like really training or something.
Jay, I thought about it.
I thought about this.
对，我只是，我打得太多了，不应该打得那么烂。我需要更有纪律性，而且如果我要为自己打得不好而心烦意乱的话，我实际上需要有一个理由。换句话说，我需要开始真正地训练或者做点别的。杰，我想过了。我考虑过这个。
And this is not a joke.
We joke about this a lot.
We're going to get to your guests.
I feel badly for them.
But I just want to say this.
You, yesterday, and he does this a lot, did this the last two days.
We're going to, everybody's like, hey, do you want a little bit of food?
They got a little snack shack and I get like a little chicken salad, maybe a thing.
这不是开玩笑。我们经常拿这个开玩笑。我们马上会采访你的嘉宾。我为他们感到难过。但我只想说这个。你昨天，而且他经常这样，过去两天都这样。我们去那儿，每个人都说，嘿，你想吃点东西吗？他们有个小吃亭，我拿了一点鸡肉沙拉，可能还有别的东西。
And Jason, the last two days goes, yeah, just get me a cup of sliced apples.
That's all he had.
No way.
And I'm like, he's starving to death.
That's what's going on.
But I still can't shake these five or ten pounds.
Dude, Jason, I told Jason, if he loses 10 pounds,
I'm taking him to the fucking hospital.
然后杰森过去两天都说，行，给我来一小杯切好的苹果。他就吃了那个。不可能。而我在想，他这是要饿死了。这就是当时的情况。但我还是甩不掉这五到十磅肉。老兄，杰森，我告诉杰森，如果他再瘦十磅，我就带他去他妈的医院。
Yeah, you don't need to lose any more weight, Jason.
Sean, he ate a cup of sliced apples, that's it.
I'm like, that's not enough when you're watching seven months.
With a cup of nuts on top of them.
Oh, fuck.
I'm covered there during the day from not eating.
Yes, tired.
I came home, you know what I did well?
对，你不需要再减重了，杰森。肖恩，他吃了一杯切好的苹果，就没了。我在想，当你连续演七场秀的时候，这根本不够。上面还撒了一把坚果。哦，操。我白天不吃东西，全靠那个撑着。是的，累了。我回到家，你知道我做了什么吗？
Here's the sickness.
I came home, I saw Amanda in the kitchen.
She's like, hi, what's wrong?
I go, nothing, I'm a disaster.
I'm embarrassed because I'm in a bad move because of golf.
She goes, really?
I go, yeah.
She goes, we want to talk about it?
这就是病态之处。我回到家，看到阿曼达在厨房里。她说，嗨，怎么了？我说，没事，我太糟糕了。我很尴尬，因为我打高尔夫球心情不好。她说，真的吗？我说，对。她说，我们想聊聊吗？
I said, you don't want any part of me.
I'm going to the gym.
So I put on my gym clothes, and I went,
and I ran on the elliptical for an hour
and then sweat it out in the hot box for an hour.
So two hours, I just had to get into a deep sweat
to get all the rage out of me.
By the way, what you don't hear in there
我说，你一点都不想沾上我。我要去健身房。于是我穿上健身服，去了健身房，在椭圆机上跑了一个小时，然后又在高温桑拿房里汗蒸了一个小时。所以整整两个小时，我必须大汗淋漓，才能把体内所有的怒火都排出来。顺便说一句，你在那里听不到的是，
is any nutrition going in.
I know.
That's what I'm saying.
His blood sugar is plummeting.
That's what your body is like screaming at you
for like, fuck up.
Both of you just shrieve.
There we go.
有任何营养摄入。我知道。这就是我要说的。他的血糖在骤降。这就是你的身体在对你大喊大叫的声音，去你的吧。你们俩都干瘪了。好了。
You don't know what the hell you're talking about.
Let's get to your guest, huh?
Yeah.
Unless you got some other...
Right.
Yes, no, I do.
I want to get to...
But I want to remind anybody,
你根本不知道自己在胡说八道什么。我们来聊聊你的嘉宾吧，好吗？好。除非你还有别的……对。是的，不，我有。我想谈谈……但我想提醒任何人，
if you're interested in what you're hearing,
we have actual actual pictures of us doing this too.
Moving pictures there on Max,
Smartless on the road,
the dock that me, Will and Sean are enjoying,
but we're a little biased.
We're in it.
But if you're interested, it's on Max there,
如果你对你听到的话感兴趣，我们在Max上也有我们做这件事的真实照片。移动影像就在Max上，《一路聪明的无知》（Smartless on the Road），我和威尔还有肖恩正在享受这部纪录片，不过我们有点主观。我们参与其中。但如果你感兴趣的话，它就在Max上，
our little docu-series called Smartless on the Road.
You know, May 23rd on Max was
the day that's right yeah yeah and they all came out at the same time and you can get all six episodes
at the same time yeah if you're yeah look at that binger binge away yeah all right all right okay my guest
fellas listeners do you like funny people sure do talented people kind people what if you manage
to pack that into one woman add two scoops of charm and a couple conversation skills and what do you
get you get our next guest gang she's an american actress starring a
a new show, which I'm very lucky enough to be a producer on.
我们的这个小纪录片系列叫《一路聪明的无知》。你知道的，Max上的5月23日就是那个日子，对，是的，是的，而且它们是一次性全部上线的，你可以一次性看完全部六集，是的，如果你是，是的，看那个，疯狂刷剧吧，疯狂刷剧吧，好吧，好吧，好的，我的嘉宾们，听众朋友们，你们喜欢有趣的人吗？当然喜欢。有才华的人，善良的人。如果你能把这些全部浓缩到一个女人身上，再加上两勺魅力和一点对话技巧，你会得到什么？你会得到我们的下一位嘉宾，伙计们，她是一位美国女演员，主演了一部新节目，我非常幸运能担任制片人。
She's a new mom, an ex-teness player, and horseback writer.
She's a native California in a proud Sagittarius
and the daughter of Lane and Gary.
Please welcome pure sunlight wrapped in skin, Miss Kaylee Cuoco.
Oh, good.
Look at her go.
Look at her quoco.
You ever been called Sunshine Rapped in Skin?
她是一位新手妈妈，前网球运动员，也是个马术爱好者。她是一个土生土长的加州人，一个骄傲的射手座，也是莱恩和加里的女儿。请欢迎这抹披着人皮的纯粹阳光，凯莉·库柯（Kaylee Cuoco）小姐。哦，好。看她走过来。看我们的库柯。你以前被人叫做“披着人皮的阳光”吗？
No, that was so sweet.
That was a first.
I was literally very much enjoying your guys' car.
I was trying to hold my hand over.
my mouth because I was dying laughing at the whole rage thing.
You're the only one.
Yeah, no.
Sean, at your disorder, which I think I have, the fainting disorder with the needles.
没有，这太甜了。这还是第一次。我刚才其实非常享受你们的汽车对话。我一直在试图用手捂住嘴，因为我快被你们整个发火的段子笑死了。你是唯一一个笑的。是的，不。肖恩，你那个病症，我觉得我也有，就是对针头有晕血晕针的那种病症。
That's true.
Yes.
Well, then that gets me into my first question.
During my deep research, because I'm a crack journalist, you had a horse riding accident
where you almost lost your leg.
I'm not exposing anything big here.
This was already out.
Oh, yeah.
确实如此。是的。好吧，那这就引出了我的第一个问题。在我深入的研究中，因为我是一个顶尖记者，你曾有过一次骑马事故，当时你差点失去一条腿。我可不是在爆什么惊天大料。这事早就公开了。哦，对。
How did you deal with all?
You're never exposing anything big.
Don't worry.
So.
Hey, Will, that sounds like a sexual insult.
No, that's good.
Now, I'm going to let you correct that for a second
because it really sounded like a sexual insult.
你是怎么处理这一切的？你从来没爆过什么大料。别担心。所以。嘿，威尔，听起来像是个性侮辱。不，这很好。现在，我要让你纠正一下这个说法，因为听起来真的很像性侮辱。
I want to interrupt and just say, hi, Kaylee.
How are you?
Hi, Kaylee.
Hi, guys.
I'm sorry to be here.
I feel like we've only met once before
at something that you were hosting.
You were backstage and you were like in a complete blackout,
我想打断一下，只想说，嗨，凯莉。你好吗？嗨，凯莉。嗨，伙计们。很遗憾能来到这里。我觉得我们以前只在某个由你主持的活动上见过一次面。你当时在后台，而且好像处于完全断片的状态，
it seemed like.
Oh, I was?
No, you had to do a bunch of stuff.
She's probably focused.
She's professional.
She was focused.
I've never been focused in my life.
That is shocking.
看起来是这样的。哦，是吗？不，你当时得做一堆事情。她可能很专注。她很专业。她当时很专注。我这辈子从来没专注过。这太令人震惊了。
But I'm so glad to be here.
I'm nervous.
You guys is like one of the best podcasts.
And my sister, it's her favorite one.
And she's like, if you mess this up,
come on.
There's nothing to mess up.
但我很高兴来到这里。我很紧张。你们的节目就像是最棒的播客之一。我姐姐，这是她最喜欢的节目。她说过，如果你把这搞砸了，走着瞧。没有什么可搞砸的。没有什么可搞砸的。
This is the best it gets, I've seen.
We're not going to let you get a word in edgewise.
Don't worry about it.
Jason's got a big question for you.
So settle in.
I hope you packed a lunch.
So you're riding a horse.
You're riding a horse.
这是我见过的最棒的节目了。我们不会让你有机会插话的。别担心。杰森有个大问题要问你。所以做好准备。我希望你带了午餐。所以你在骑马。你在骑马。
You're jumping over gates and going around barrels
and whatever the fuck you do.
And then you get, and then the horse falls.
Or you fall.
A horse falls on you, lands on the leg,
is stuck on the leg, broken the leg.
broke broken the leg,
did you ask the horse to get off?
你在跨越栅栏、绕着木桶跑，或者随便你们在干什么鬼。然后你，然后马摔倒了。或者你摔倒了。马倒在你身上，压在你的腿上，卡在你的腿上，把腿摔断了。把腿摔断了，你有没有要求那匹马从你身上下来？
Did the horse get off immediately?
Wait, how long ago was this?
This was a while ago.
This was, let's see, it was beginning of Big Bang
and we've been probably, I don't know,
12, 13 years ago.
Oh my God, okay.
So, guys, she almost lost her leg.
马立刻下来了吗？等等，这是多久以前的事了？这已经是很久以前了。这是，让我想想，那是《生活大爆炸》刚开始的时候，大概，我不知道，12、13年前吧。哦，天哪，好吧。所以，伙计们，她差点失去了一条腿。
I once asked a horse to get off
during a Big Bang.
I mean.
It's a family show, Will.
It's his birthday.
He's on fire.
You really almost lost your leg.
on this?
我曾在《生活大爆炸》拍摄期间要求一匹马下来过。我的意思是。这是个家庭节目，威尔。今天是他的生日。他状态正火呢。你真的差点失去一条腿吗？
Well, yeah, no, it was a bad accident.
It was a very bad accident.
And, yeah, he, I had fallen, the fall didn't hurt me.
He ended up stepping on me.
And I remember, I know.
And the crazy part is, I remember when it.
Sean's down.
And he can't dart his eyes, so he's just screwed.
嗯，是的，不，那是一场严重的事故。那是一场非常严重的事故。而且，是的，他，我摔了下去，摔倒本身并没有伤害我。他最后踩到了我。我记得，我懂的。最疯狂的部分是，我记得当时……肖恩倒下了。他眼睛不能转动，所以他完蛋了。
Scotty.
Scotty, get the paddles.
So he's done, don't face.
Kaylee, how old were you when this happened?
I was, my God, I can't do math.
Early 20s?
It's probably 22.
Yeah.
斯科蒂。斯科蒂，把除颤器拿来。所以他完了，别面对现实了。凯莉，这事发生时你多大？我当时，天哪，我算不出数学。二十岁出头？大概22岁吧。是的。
Wow.
Okay.
So now, but you had to sign something before surgery that gives the doctor permission that
once they get in there and they see that maybe we might not be able to save the leg that
you won't sue them if you wake up without the leg.
Yes.
It was that serious?
是的。哇。好吧。所以现在，但你在手术前必须签署一份文件，授权医生一旦他们进去发现可能无法保住你的腿时，如果你醒来时发现腿没了，你不会起诉他们。是的。有那么严重吗？
It was really serious.
So I had to go under.
I had to sign something.
Yeah, it's exactly right.
And luckily I came out and I was.
So, but wait, wait, talk to, do you remember?
You probably don't remember because you were so under anesthesia.
But when you first woke up was your first look down to see a.
真的非常严重。所以我得去做手术。我必须签署文件。是的，完全没错。幸运的是我醒来时，我……所以，但是等等，等等，你跟……你还记得吗？你可能不记得了，因为你麻醉得太深了。但当你刚醒来时，你的第一眼是不是低头去看……
The leg was still there?
You remember that?
Yes, totally.
Oh, yeah.
No, I have a very deep, yeah.
What are we talking about?
We're talking about it separated from your body?
I had a compound fracture, so for those who don't know, it's the bone that comes out of your leg.
腿还在不在？你还记得那个吗？是的，完全记得。哦，对。不，我有很深的，对。我们在说什么？我们在说它从你身体上分离了吗？我当时是粉碎性骨折，所以对于那些不知道的人来说，就是骨头从你的腿里戳了出来。
Out of the skin.
Wait, which bone?
Oh, that's what I've got.
My tibia fibula, so it is near my ankle and my knee.
My bone's always coming out.
Will, this is family.
Will's always caught with his bone out.
Yeah, no, right.
戳出皮肤。等等，哪根骨头？哦，我有这个。我的胫骨腓骨，所以它靠近我的脚踝和膝盖。我的骨头总是戳出来。威尔，这是家庭节目。威尔的骨头总是露在外面。对，没错。
That's what it's called.
Okay, sorry.
Oh, my God.
I'm going to have to update my...
It was almost my first spit take in 150.
I'm going to have to update my dating profile.
Oh, my God.
That's what it's called.
原来这就叫这个。好吧，抱歉。哦，天哪。我得更新我的……这差点让我把150集以来的第一口喷出来。我得更新我的约会资料了。哦，天哪。原来这就叫这个。
You're creating a compound fracture.
Yes.
Okay, so wait.
Don't come in here.
I've got a compound fracture.
So wait.
So your bone is sticking out of your...
The top part of your thigh or your bottom part of your knee?
你造成了一次粉碎性骨折。是的。所以等等。别上这儿来。我粉碎性骨折了。所以等等。所以你的骨头戳出了你的……是大腿上部还是膝盖下部？
No, no, no, no, no.
Ankle, ankle, knee.
Okay.
So there was two.
Yep.
Yeah, and so it just was a horrible, horrible, horrible break.
And I had been in the-
Why did you say it didn't hurt?
不，不，不，不，不。脚踝，脚踝，膝盖。好吧。所以有两个。是的。是的，所以这是一个糟糕透顶、糟糕透顶、糟糕透顶的骨折。我当时在——你为什么说不疼？
No, it did, oh, no, it did hurt?
Oh, my God.
I was going to say, when I fell, the fall didn't break my life.
My fall wasn't a big deal.
He stepped to me, and I remember clear as day.
Because it takes a second when something is that bad.
I was like, did I, did I just fall on a,
whole thing of leaves because I heard all the cracking.
不，疼，哦，不，确实疼？哦，天哪。我本想说，当我摔倒时，摔倒并没有弄断我的腿。我的摔倒不是什么大事。他踩到了我，我记得清清楚楚。因为当事情有那么严重时，需要缓一缓。我当时想，我是不是，我是不是掉进了一堆树叶里，因为我听到了所有的碎裂声。
Yeah, so I was like, are there a leave?
And it took me like five or ten seconds to actually realize it wasn't just 400 leaves.
It was my bones.
Yeah.
So what do you have pins and rods in there now?
Yeah, I have, you got to do.
Do you set off metal detectors?
No, I always thought I would, but it never happened.
对，所以我当时想，这里有树叶吗？我花了五到十秒钟才真正意识到那不仅仅是400片树叶。那是我的骨头。是的。那你现在里面有钢钉和钢棒吗？对，我有，你必须得弄。你会触发金属探测器吗？没有，我一直以为我会，但从来没有发生过。
Oh, my God.
What was the recovery like for that?
Like, just.
You know what's crazy?
So I was shooting Big Bang.
It was on a Friday after work.
And so I was supposed to go to work on Monday.
They put you behind the bar, right?
哦，天哪。那时的康复过程是什么样的？就像是。你知道最疯狂的是什么吗？当时我在拍《生活大爆炸》。那是周五下班后。所以周一我本该去上班。他们把你安排在酒吧后面，对吧？
They gave you like a bar job.
Oh, my, yes.
I'm like, I have to call Chuck Lori and tell him right now that I am.
The great Chuck Lori.
Just, yes, the great Chuck Lori, but you don't want to make that call.
And so they literally didn't think I would like walk for three months.
They thought I would not walk for three months.
I was walking in a week with a boot.
他们给你安排了一个酒吧的工作。哦，天哪，是的。我当时想，我必须马上打电话给查克·洛尔（Chuck Lori），告诉他我是……伟大的查克·洛尔。只是，是的，伟大的查克·洛尔，但你可不想打这通电话。所以他们简直以为我三个月内都无法走路。他们以为我三个月内都无法走路。我一个星期后就拄着靴子走路了。
I was back to work in two weeks.
It was like miraculous.
Wow.
Yeah.
I mean, you know, they always say the worst.
And then I ended up being okay, but like it, they were very good.
So wait, but you still now have, because listening to the story, I'm on pins and needles.
So you actually have pins in there for real?
两周后我就回去工作了。这简直就像个奇迹。哇。是的，我的意思是，你知道，他们总是把情况说得最糟。然后我最后没事了，但就像是，他们非常好。所以等等，但你现在依然有，因为听了这个故事，我听得提心吊胆的。所以你里面真的有钢钉？
Yes, I do.
They didn't take those out.
They're not planning on taking those out?
No, I went back in years later and I was like, it's just bad to have in there.
And they said, honestly, the surgery would be such a pain for you.
Like, if they're not bothering you, leave it.
So I'm, I know.
So can you run and jump and do anything?
是的，我有的。他们没有把那些取出来。他们不打算把它们取出来吗？没有，我几年后又去复查过，然后我说，一直留着这东西不太好吧。他们说，老实说，手术对你来说会是个极大的痛苦。如果它们不困扰你，就别管它。所以我是，我知道。那你现在能跑、能跳、能做任何事吗？
Oh, yeah.
Do you have fun scars on the bottom of your leg?
Yeah.
I do.
That's cool.
That's very cool.
I don't have any good scars.
You guys have any good scars?
哦，当然。你腿上有很酷的伤疤吗？对。我有的。太酷了。太酷了。我没有什么好看的伤疤。你们有什么好看的伤疤吗？
Yeah.
It makes you feel like a badass.
I fell off the bunk bed when I was a kid and I had on the side of my head.
Oh, bless your heart.
Oh, the bunk bed.
I've never met a guy that fell off the top bunk.
You know, they usually have little bars up there to help.
I had a bar online.
有。这让你觉得自己像个狠角色。我小时候从双层床掉下来过，我头上有一道疤。哦，可怜的孩子。哦，双层床。我从来没见过哪个家伙从上铺掉下来的。你知道，他们通常上面都有小护栏来着。我当时有护栏的。
Although you just confirmed something that I've unsuspected.
What?
That you're atop.
Yeah.
I mean, I was going to say.
And I was like, you know what I'll say.
I do have this scar.
Wait, Shawnee, wait, there it is.
尽管你刚刚证实了我一直以来的某种猜测。什么？你是上面的那个（Top）。对。我的意思是，我本来想说的。我确实有这个疤。等等，肖尼，等等，在那儿呢。
Yeah, that's called a belly button.
Sean, you've lost so much fucking weight.
Yeah, you're really, I've lost a lot of weight.
I know, but I'll gain it right away.
Will, what did I get you for your birthday, Will?
Sean sent me today, this fucking asshole.
He sent me four large things of ice cream.
And he said, this is what I used to get fat.
对，那叫肚脐眼。肖恩，你他妈瘦了好多。对，你真的，我瘦了很多。我知道，但我马上就会胖回去的。威尔，我送了你什么生日礼物，威尔？肖恩今天送给我，这个混蛋。他寄给我四盆大桶的冰激凌。他说，这就是我以前用来长胖的东西。
This is what I eat to get fat.
Happy birthday.
And I'm like, you asshole, because now I'm going to eat it.
If it's calling me, if it's in the freezer.
What kind of ice cream was it?
It's the best.
Huggin does chocolate and coffee and vanilla.
Yeah.
这就是我吃胖的东西。生日快乐。然后我说，你个混蛋，因为我待会儿就要吃它了。如果它在那儿召唤我，如果它在冰箱里的话。那是什么冰激凌？这是最棒的。哈根达斯有巧克力、咖啡和香草味。对。
It's the best.
Hung enough.
So creative.
It's the best.
You either go with the best or you don't.
You've gotten into it since then, right?
Well, you opened it up?
Not this morning.
这是最棒的。哈根达斯。太有创意了。这是最棒的。你要么选最好的，要么就不选。你从那以后就开始吃了，对吧？好吧，你打开它了吗？不是今天早上。
I had cake last night with the kids.
We had ice cream cake because that's my favorite and yellow cake with chocolate frosting.
That's exactly right.
Did you use the cake?
No, no, Mercy made it, who is here, and she's a great cake.
The cake lady's great, but Mercy makes it an incredible cake.
And so I will say, because we talked about it earlier, Jason, you going in, I ate the cake.
I ate early with the kids.
我昨晚和孩子们一起吃了蛋糕。我们吃了冰激凌蛋糕，因为那是我的最爱，还有黄巧克力糖霜的黄色蛋糕。完全正确。你用了那个蛋糕吗？不，不，梅西（Mercy）做的，她就在这儿，她是个做蛋糕的高手。蛋糕女士很棒，但梅西做的蛋糕简直不可思议。所以我得说，因为我们之前讨论过，杰森，你进去时，我吃了蛋糕。我和孩子们吃得比较早。
And about 45 minutes after eating two pieces of cake, because one of each.
Night, night.
I went, no, I went, motherfucker, and I went down.
I came down into the gym, and I worked out for an hour.
Oh, you did?
You have to.
For you.
Did you zip into the rubber suit?
在大约吃了两块蛋糕45分钟后，因为每种吃了一块。晚安，晚安。我去了，不，我去了，我这个操蛋的，然后我下楼了。我来到健身房，锻炼了一个小时。哦，真的吗？你必须得去。为了你。你钻进橡胶套装里了吗？
Of course, I always wear the rubber suit, as you know.
We'll be right back.
All right, back to the show.
Kaylee, you always look so thin.
Do you go crazy with junk food at all, ever?
Oh, yeah.
Do you?
当然，如你所知，我总是穿着橡胶套装。我们马上回来。好的，回到节目中。凯莉，你总是看起来那么瘦。你平时会疯狂地吃垃圾食品吗？哦，会。哦，会。会吗？
I mean, you know, I definitely do.
You know what else?
Kaylee, you've got great skin.
I've always noticed that about you.
Yes.
Thank you.
You've got really nice.
You've got really nice skin.
我的意思是，你知道的，我绝对会。还有你知道吗？凯莉，你的皮肤真好。我一直注意到你这一点。是的。谢谢。你的皮肤真的很好。你皮肤真的很好。
Well, that's so nice.
Thank you.
I know.
it's really nice to have a work thing this morning
and not have to do any hair and makeup whatsoever.
I was very excited.
You know, that's on purpose.
You know, while we get to look at each other,
哇，太好了。谢谢。我知道。今天早上能有个工作通告，而且完全不用弄头发和化妆，感觉真的太棒了。我当时非常兴奋。你知道，那是故意的。你知道，当我们看着对方的时候，
you know, it's like I don't want anyone to have to go,
no hair and makeup and the whole.
I mean, you guys have to look at me,
but other than that, no one else does.
Why do you have such good skin?
Do you stay out of the sun?
No, I don't stay out of the sun.
I've got quite a skin regimen on my little products.
你知道，这就好像我不想让任何人不得不去说，没有发型化妆以及诸如此类的话。我的意思是，你们得看着我，但除此之外，没有别人需要看。为什么你的皮肤这么好？你平时不出门晒太阳吗？不，我没有不出门晒太阳。我有一套相当不错的皮肤护理流程和我的小产品。
But I'll bet, but you were very good about putting on sunblock
when you were almost a,
semi-pro tennis star when you were a youngster, yes?
Wait, what?
Let's get into that.
Yes, she decided at 16, I could go this way, or we could try acting.
You were a tennis pro?
I did.
但我敢打赌，你以前在年轻时差点成为半职业网球选手时，在涂防晒霜这方面一定做得很好，对吧？等等，什么？我们来聊聊这个。是的，她16岁时决定，我可以走这条路，或者我们可以尝试演戏。你曾是一名网球运动员？是的。
I played tennis my whole juniors when I was young.
Yeah, that's all I did.
And I really thought I was going to be a professional tennis player when I was much younger.
Where was that?
Camero.
Yeah, in Camerrio.
And then, southern California.
And then, but I traveled all over the country and I loved it.
我年轻时整个少年时期都在打网球。是的，我当时只做这个。而且我很小的时候真的以为自己会成为一名职业网球运动员。是在哪里？卡马里奥。对，在卡马里奥。然后，南加州。然后，但我去全国各地比赛，我热爱它。
and then realized, oh my God, and I was auditioning and working,
and then I got my first show, and I was like,
to be a professional tennis player, you got to really just do that.
I thought I don't know if I can give myself to both.
So I was like, I'm never going to play again,
and I put my rackets down at, like, 16,
but I played very competitively for years and years as a young teen.
Wow.
然后意识到，哦，天哪，我当时在试镜和工作，然后我得到了我的第一部戏，我就想，要成为一名职业网球运动员，你真的必须全身心投入那件事。我觉得我不知道自己能否两头兼顾。所以我当时想，我再也不打球了，我在16岁左右放下了球拍，但我年轻时作为青少年参加过多年竞争激烈的比赛。哇。
And traveled all over, and I loved it.
Yeah, I loved it.
That's so hard.
That takes so much training and so much dedication.
I loved it.
Do you still play a tiny bit?
So I stopped for years.
You know, I think when you're competitive in any sport, it's not fun.
而且到处旅行，我很喜欢它。是的，我很喜欢。这太难了。这需要那么多的训练和奉献精神。我很喜欢。你现在还偶尔打一点吗？所以我停了多年。你知道，我觉得当你对任何一项运动抱有竞技心时，它就不有趣了。
The fun kind of leaves a little bit.
So to play for fun was not something I wanted to do.
So over COVID, my girlfriend, who is my oldest friend, who was my doubles partner when we were really young,
she's like, let's start playing doubles together during COVID and like entered tournaments
and it was hysterical.
And I loved it.
Because it's socially distant, right?
That's why you could do it during COVID.
乐趣会流失一点点。所以为了好玩而去打球并不是我想做的事。于是在疫情期间，我的闺蜜，也就是我最好的朋友，我们很小的时候是双打搭档，她说，我们在疫情期间开始一起打双打吧，还去参加了比赛，简直太搞笑了。我很喜欢它。因为那是保持社交距离的运动，对吧？这就是为什么你能在疫情期间打网球的原因。
That's why Will got him back into golf, son of a bitch.
Yeah, I heard that you had some rage, but that was an interesting story.
Real issues.
Which time did you hear about?
You talked about the time the guy that didn't charge his Tesla?
That's one of the greatest stories ever.
Now, that's a perfect example of me two years ago versus now.
I exit myself from the situation before I'm accountable for my mood.
这就是为什么威尔重新开始打高尔夫球，你这个混蛋。对，我听说你有点暴躁，不过那是个有趣的故事。真正的问题。你听说的是哪一次？你谈到那个不给特斯拉充电的家伙的那次吗？那是史上最棒的故事之一。现在，那是我两年前与现在的完美对比。我在为自己的情绪负责之前，就主动退出了那个情况。
to do it.
I will separate myself from people
and just deal with it on my own.
I will say that he did approach all of us
who were playing with him yesterday
and said, one by one.
I'm not joking.
And he said, hey, man, I'm really sorry
去这样做。我会把自己和人群隔离开来，然后自己独自处理。我要说的是，他确实走近了昨天和我们一起打球的所有人，一个接一个地。我没开玩笑。他说，嘿，伙计，我真的很抱歉，
that I've been kind of grinding and cranky today.
And he went and I heard him say to the other guys.
And I thought, fuck, this is a new Jason.
That's sweet.
My beautiful wife, Amanda, is teaching me
how to be a better man.
Kaylee, so did you play.
Guys, don't fight.
我今天有点死磕和暴躁。然后他去了，我听到他对其他人这么说。我想，操，这是一个崭新的杰森。太甜了。我美丽的妻子阿曼达正在教我如何成为一个更好的男人。凯莉，那你打过……伙计们，别吵了。
We want to talk to Kaylee so bad.
I just want to know if she had
When you played when you...
Yes.
Was your worst moment.
Did you ever say you can't be serious?
Oh, my God.
Are you kidding?
我们太想和凯莉聊天了。我只想知道她有没有……你以前打球的时候……是的。你最糟糕的时刻是什么？你有没有说过“你在开玩笑吧”？哦，天哪。你在开玩笑吗？
I broke so many rackets.
I had a real bad attitude, actually.
Did you really?
To this day, you don't want to play Scrabble with me.
I am the worst.
You don't want to play Scrabble.
I'll kick your ass and Scrabble.
Exactly.
我砸了那么多球拍。其实我当时态度真的很不好。真的吗？直到今天，你都不想跟我玩拼字游戏。我是最差劲的。你不想玩拼字游戏的。我在拼字游戏里会把你屁股踢开。没错。
That's how I get, too.
I lose my shit.
I love to win.
I don't fuck around.
It's not a joke to me.
Game night is not...
No one wants to let me participate in game night
because I don't make it fun for anybody.
我也会变成那样。我一输就情绪失控。我喜欢赢。我绝不胡闹。对我来说这不是开玩笑。游戏之夜不是……没有人想让我参加游戏之夜，因为我让所有人都玩得不开心。
Do you have a game night going?
on right now?
Like in this moment?
No.
No, you're in general.
Because Shawnee,
sometimes you do game nights.
I like games.
你现在正举办游戏之夜吗？就此刻而言？没有。没有，你一般而言。因为肖尼，有时你会办游戏之夜。我喜欢游戏。
We love game nights.
We are obsessed.
But again...
When you say we're talking about Tom Pelfrey,
are we not?
Me and Tom Pelfrey, we love game nights.
Easy on the eyes.
What a guy.
我们热爱游戏之夜。我们对此着迷。但话说回来……当你提到“我们”时，是指汤姆·佩尔弗雷（Tom Pelfrey），对吧？我和汤姆·佩尔弗雷，我们热爱游戏之夜。非常养眼。真是个好人。
I love that.
Is that your guy?
Is Tom Pelfry your guy?
Tom Pelfrey's my guy.
We love game nights.
Okay.
I met him because of,
我喜欢这样。那是你的真命天子吗？汤姆·佩尔弗雷是你的真命天子吗？那是你的真命天子吗？汤姆·佩尔弗雷是我的真命天子。我们热爱游戏之夜。好吧。我遇到他是因为，
it's really, I have to think, Jason.
They met at the Ozark
a rap party, if you can believe that.
Oh, really? You were the reason I met him. Yes.
Yeah. Now, walk us through this story.
Did he know you were coming or did you know he was going to be there?
Was there any sort of set up there at all? I don't remember.
I knew. So we have the same, I'm sure you've heard this story a million times,
这真的，让我想想，杰森。如果你敢相信的话，他们是在《黑钱胜地》（Ozark）的杀青派对上认识的。哦，真的吗？你是我们相识的原因。是的。是的。现在，带我们回顾一下这个故事。他知道你要来吗？还是你知道他在那儿？那里有什么刻意的安排吗？我不记得了。我知道。所以我们有同一个——我确信你已经听过这个故事一百万遍了，
but we have the same manager. And she, the December, that past December, she had said,
I want to set you up with someone that I know. And I said it was too soon after my last
relationship. I was like, no, I'm not ready.
She goes noted fine.
So in April, I was going to New York to promote flight attendant and my manager, Andrea,
was like.
Yeah, so technical.
You're sure great, Matt.
但我们有同一个经纪人。她，那年的十二月，也就是去年十二月，她曾说过，我想把你介绍给我认识的一个人。我说，在我上一段恋情结束后这么做太快了。我说，不，我还没准备好。她说，知道了，好吧。所以在四月份，我要去纽约宣传《空乘危机》（The Flight Attendant），我的经纪人安德烈（Andrea）就说……是的，太专业了。你真棒，马特。
You can edit the applause in later.
That would be great.
It's in.
And we put it a little in for Big Bang earlier.
Go ahead.
Thank you.
No, thank you.
These are great shows.
你可以在后期把掌声剪进去。那就太好了。已经剪进去了。我们之前在《生活大爆炸》那里加了一点。继续吧。谢谢。不，谢谢。这些都是很棒的节目。
These are, thank you.
Please continue.
So she decided to come with me to New York to just hang out.
And she goes, actually, I'm going to, my other client is going, I'm going to see my other
client there.
and she didn't even really say it was Tom,
but she said, I'm going to go to the Ozark premiere,
and it's during the week, and do you want to come with me?
这些都是，谢谢。请继续。所以她决定陪我去纽约散散心，她说，其实，我要去，我的另一个客户也要去，我要去见我的另一个客户，而且她甚至没有真正说是汤姆，但她说，我要去《黑钱胜地》的首映礼，是在工作日，你想跟我一起去吗？
And it wasn't...
And you were like, what's Ozark?
Nobody knows what that is.
100%. I never heard of the show.
I didn't want to go.
And so she said, come with me, and I was like, I was like, okay.
And I went with her and got all dolled out.
I knew I would meet him, of course,
而且这并不是……而你当时的反应是，什么是《黑钱胜地》？根本没人知道那是什么。百分之百。我以前从没听说过这个节目。我不想去。所以她说，跟我一起去吧，然后我说，我当时想，好吧。我和她一起去了，盛装打扮了一番。我知道我会见到他，当然，
but it didn't occur to me about anything else.
And when I got there, we were a little late,
and so everyone was piling into the theater.
I didn't have a minute to meet him, and I was actually standing near, waiting in the line of the restroom.
I was faced away, and I overheard, you know, he's got a very sexy voice, Mr. Tom Pelfrey.
Yeah, it does.
And I overheard him say to our manager, where is this Kaylee?
Uh-oh.
但我压根没想过其他任何事。当我到达那里时，我们稍微迟到了，所以每个人都正蜂拥进入剧院。我根本没有时间去见他，我当时其实正站在洗手间排队的队伍附近。我背对着那边，然后我无意中听到，你知道的，他有一副非常性感的嗓音，汤姆·佩尔弗雷先生。是的，确实有。我无意中听到他对我们的经纪人说，这个凯莉在哪里？哦哦。
And I turned around and it was like...
She's right in front of waiting to take a dump.
And you were like, don't...
That's what I said, yeah.
That's what I said to him.
And he thought it was really cool that I was so open.
No, I saw him, and it was like this very strange, like the world kind of stopped.
Really?
然后我转过身去，那种感觉就像是……她正站在前面等着上厕所。而你当时说，别……我当时就是这么对他说，是的。我就是这么对他的。他觉得我很酷，因为我很坦率。不，我看到他了，那种感觉非常诡异，就像世界突然静止了一样。真的吗？
Yeah, it was really wild.
He gave me this huge bear hug.
And like I said, there were so many people piling and it wasn't a moment to really talk.
And so we all just, I was like, nice to meet you.
Yeah.
I mean, he just real easy with that quick smile, right?
He's got a nice, that laugh.
Come on.
是的，真的很疯狂。他给了我一个巨大的熊抱。就像我说的，当时有太多人涌入，根本没有时间真正聊天。所以我们大家只是，我当时说，很高兴认识你。我的意思是，他带着那种快速的微笑显得非常随性，对吧？他笑起来很迷人，那种笑声。拜托。
Uh-huh.
Infectious.
And so how many years has that been going on?
We've been together for one year.
We got pregnant two months in.
We have a baby.
We were like, boom, boom, boom.
Wow.
嗯哼。具有感染力。所以这种情况已经持续多少年了？我们在一起一年了。我们在两个月内就怀孕了。我们有了个孩子。我们的节奏是，轰，轰，轰。哇。
We're insane.
Let's go back to my room.
You know, we're not 20 anymore.
We were like, we're doing this or not?
So Matilda is a full month?
Two months.
Five weeks old today, you guys.
Oh, my gosh.
我们疯了。我们回我房间吧。你知道的，我们不再是20岁了。我们当时想，到底做还是不做？所以玛蒂尔达（Matilda）满一个月了吗？两个月。你们大家，她今天五周大了。哦，天哪。
Congratulations.
Thank you.
Wait, you had a baby five weeks ago?
Can you believe that?
No, I can't.
It's crazy.
I know.
And look at you.
恭喜。谢谢。等等，你五周前生了个孩子？真敢相信吗？不，我不敢。太疯狂了。我知道。看看你。
You don't look like you had a bed.
Like, you're just, you look great.
Tom.
Tom actually carried it.
Oh, no kidding.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, that's interesting.
If a man could.
你看上去一点也不像刚生过孩子。就像，你状态太棒了。汤姆。其实是汤姆怀的。哦，真的假的。对，对。哦，那挺有意思的。如果男人可以的话。
He's very progressive.
Tom would carry the baby.
He is that obsessed.
But how do you have energy?
Like, aren't you exhausted?
Or do you have one of those good babies that sleeps all the time?
She, no, she's pretty awesome.
Look, I'm not going to lie.
他非常前卫。汤姆会怀这个孩子。他迷恋到这种程度。但你怎么会有精力？难道你不累吗？还是说你有一个那种全天都在睡觉的乖宝宝？她，不，她相当棒。听着，我不会撒谎。
We have some very nice help.
Yes.
I'm a big advocate for that.
But we have very nice help, which is why I can, like,
our relationship is so survived because we have all this help with this baby.
Listen, when I'm.
Oh, my God.
I mean.
我们请了很好的帮手。是的。我非常支持这一点。但我们有很好的帮手，这也是为什么我能，我们的关系能维系得这么好，因为我们在带这个孩子上有这么多的帮助。听着，当我是。哦，天哪。我是说。
Yeah, I mean, if he can't, have you got in-laws or whatever,
I'm just such a big, big fan of, like, it makes you better.
Think about this, in the old days it used to be,
people all lived with their families in the olden times.
And you had family around, and family would help out,
and you'd have siblings and parents and grandparents and stuff,
and it would all have.
So you're not at the end of your rope.
是的，我是说，如果他不行，你有没有公公婆婆什么的，我简直是这种做法的超级超级粉丝，这能让你变得更好。想想看，在过去的日子里，在旧时代，人们都和家人住在一起。你身边有家人，家人会帮忙，你会有兄弟姐妹、父母和祖父母之类的人，所有人都会帮忙。所以你不会陷入山穷水尽的地步。
Yeah, and now it's different.
And it's great.
My mom is here this morning, and she was, like, so excited.
I had something I had to do so she could hang out with the baby for an hour.
So it's like, it's the best.
No, does she mom, does she mom,
Tilda like you would or do you guys have like a little bit of tension like don't start trouble no yeah my mom honestly my mom is the best and actually so is Tom's mom they are like they come in they help they don't overstep it's the best do they get along do the mom's
oh my god we're so lucky they all oddly look like each other too and they're they've become very close we're just like really lucky yeah you're very lucky we're very lucky
是的，现在情况不同了。而且这很棒。我妈妈今天早上来了，她当时，特别高兴。我有点事要做，所以她可以陪宝宝一个小时。所以这感觉，简直棒极了。不，她会像妈妈那样带Tilda吗，还是你们之间有点紧张，比如别挑事？没有，是的，我妈妈老实说我妈妈是最好的，实际上汤姆的妈妈也是，她们会过来帮忙，但不会越界，这太棒了。她们合得来吗？两个妈妈，哦天哪，我们太幸运了。她们俩长相甚至都有点奇怪地相似，而且她们关系变得非常亲密。我们就是，真的超级幸运。是的，你们真的很幸运，我们真的很幸运。
that's great i know i know five weeks old i can't do you want more kids
Yeah, we do.
Sean, are you moving a couple?
Yeah, I'm moving a couple.
Do you have any links you could send her?
Yeah, the dark web.
All right, so let's start with, now, Big Bang is something that was a Big Bang, right?
It was.
太棒了。我知道，我知道，五周大，我不能，你还想要更多孩子吗？是的，我们想。肖恩，你在搬动什么吗？是的，我在搬动几个。你有什么链接可以发给她吗？有的，暗网。好吧，那么我们从，现在，《生活大爆炸》是一件可以说是大爆炸的事情，对吧？是的。
That was a phenomenon.
Nine, ten, twelve seasons?
Twelve.
Twelve seasons?
I mean, that's incredible.
Now, could you have kept going or is it like, you know, this is the right time to end this?
You know, I'll be honest with you, and I've talked about this before, we truly, our group of actors, we thought we were 100% doing the 13th season.
We thought, we'll do a 13th, it'll be the last one, you know.
那真是一个现象级作品。九季、十季、十二季？十二季。十二季？我的天，这太不可思议了。那么，你们本可以继续拍下去，还是觉得，你知道的，这是剧集完结的正确时机？你知道的，老实说，我以前也谈过这个，我们真的，我们的演员团队，我们以为我们100%会拍第十三季。我们当时想，我们会拍第十三季，这将是最后一季，你知道的。
And this story is not new.
I'm not giving it anything away.
I mean, Jim really did.
Jim Parsons really wanted to be done, and he was kind of the first person to call it.
Okay.
And we were not, we didn't know that was happening.
We kind of all thought we were going to do another season.
But we heard it at the beginning of season 12, basically after like our second table,
而且这个故事也不是什么新鲜事。我没有剧透任何东西。我是说，吉姆确实。吉姆·帕尔森斯（Jim Parsons）真的很想收工了，他算是第一个提出不干了的人。好吧。而我们当时并不知道，我们并不知道这件事正在发生。我们其实都以为我们要拍另一季了。但我们在第12季刚开始的时候就听说了，基本上在我们进行第二次剧本围读之后，
we were told this was going to be it
and was actually kind of, I mean, as sad
as we all were and like kind of a little bit shocked,
it was cool because then we had like a whole season
to really be in the moment, play.
Yeah, it was cool. We could kind of like slowly.
It was Jim's show. Was it Jim's show?
Originally, yeah. Then it kind of became more of an ensemble.
我们被告知这就是最后一季了，实际上当时，我是说，尽管我们所有人都很难过，还有点小震惊，但这其实很酷，因为那样的话我们就有整整一季的时间真正沉浸在当下，去表演。是的，这很酷。我们可以有点像慢慢地。那是吉姆的剧。那是吉姆的剧吗？最初是的。后来它在某种程度上变得更像是一部群戏。
Yeah, he just was, he didn't, he was done.
And we were all just, oh my God, it was so shocking.
But then I think over the few weeks it was like,
okay, maybe this is the right thing.
And honestly, I mean, for me,
I wouldn't have even done.
I don't know if flight attendant would have happened.
Like the timing was actually amazing.
是的，他只是，他不想，他受够了。我们当时都，哦天哪，太震惊了。但随后我认为在过去的几周里，感觉就像，好吧，也许这是正确的决定。老实说，对我来说，我甚至都不会去拍。我不知道《空乘危机》会不会发生。所以这个时机其实太惊人了。
Everything happens for a reason.
Totally.
So we were,
it was fine.
But that routine of,
in front of a live audience,
that is a,
do you miss that?
一切发生都是有原因的。完全同意。所以我们，这很好。但是那种在现场观众面前表演的常规，那是一种，你怀念那个吗？
I mean,
it's so,
um,
I loved it.
I loved the audience.
I thought it would,
I loved,
obviously,
我是说，太，嗯，我爱它。我爱现场观众。我以为我会，我显然，
love the schedule.
It was great.
I'm happy now not doing it,
but it was such incredible memories.
I mean,
some of those live shows,
were some of the best nights of my life for sure.
I mean, my dad never missed a tape.
爱那个时间表。这太棒了。我现在不拍了也很高兴，但那真是太不可思议的回忆了。我是说，其中一些现场演出，绝对是我一生中最美好的夜晚之一。我是说，我爸爸从未错过任何一场录制。
He was in the audience every week.
Every single single evening.
He had his own chair at the back of the audience.
Couldn't sit in it.
The angel could not even see.
He was standing the whole time.
And what we'd do before each show with a little thumbs up?
He gave me a thumbs up for Curt and Paul.
他每周都在观众席里。每一个单身，每一个晚。他在观众席后面有他自己的椅子。不能坐在上面。天使甚至都看不见。他全程都在站着。我们在每场演出前都会做什么，带着一个小小的竖大拇指？他为柯特和保罗竖起了大拇指。
Every time I came out and the crew.
The whole cast would do it too.
And the crew.
Yes.
The crew started obviously to my dad.
So everyone would do this like thumbs up for my dad.
I mean, he was there.
I'm not kidding.
每次我出来的时候，剧组。整个演员阵容也都会这么做。还有剧组人员。是的。剧组人员显然也开始效仿我爸爸。所以每个人都会为我爸爸竖起大拇指。我是说，他就在那里。我没开玩笑。
every show night for 12 years.
My dad came to,
none of them.
He didn't come to any of them.
He didn't go to anything, yeah.
He didn't come to.
No, he went to Kaylee's shows.
Sean, your dad went to everyone at Kaylee's shows.
12年里的每一个演出之夜。我爸爸都来了，没有一个缺席。他一场都没来。他什么都没去，是的。他没来。没有，他去了凯莉的演出。肖恩，你爸爸去了凯莉的所有演出。
He was so wonderful.
He drove her dad.
He had a chair.
He was so into it.
Kaylee, Kaylee, how many episodes
did you guys do of Big Bang?
Oh my God.
You know what?
他太棒了。他开车送她爸爸。他有一把椅子。他太投入了。凯莉，凯莉，你们拍了多少集《生活大爆炸》？哦天哪。你知道吗？
300.
It was something like that.
I actually don't remember the number.
22 times 13, quick.
We did 24.
I'm sure there were some years
there were 24.
And yeah.
300集。差不多是这个数字。我其实记不清具体数字了。22乘以13，快算。我们拍了24集。我确信有些年份拍了24集。然后是的。
250, something like that.
It was up there.
Yeah.
300.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
That's so impressive and it's so, and I am jealous.
250集，诸如此类。数额相当大。是的。数额相当大。300集。哦，对，对。是的。这太令人印象深刻了，而且太，我甚至有点嫉妒。
It's like once in a billion.
Not just of the schedule, but of like kind of what Jason was saying.
Like being able to go and do that every week in front of the audience.
That's so, what people don't understand is how much fun.
Yeah, a live audience.
It really is so fun.
Yeah.
It's so fun.
这就像千亿分之一的概率。不仅是关于日程安排，而且就像杰森刚才说的。能够每周去观众面前表演。这太，人们不理解的是这有多么有趣。是的，现场观众。真的太有趣了。是的。太有趣了。
Now, when we're a kid and we're at home, we're playing, we're playing tennis.
Where did the whole thing?
for acting come from was
Gary or Lane?
Lane, am I saying that right?
Yeah, Lane.
Yeah, lovely.
Were they into acting at all?
现在，当我们还是个孩子，我们在家里，我们在玩，我们在打网球。演艺事业的整件事是从哪里开始的？是加里还是莱恩？莱恩，我没说错吧？是的，莱恩。是的，很可爱。他们对表演感兴趣吗？
Like who, how did this come about?
No, it was kind of great.
No, I did a lot of different things when I was younger.
You know, my, my, I would go in auditions.
Like I said, I would play tennis.
I went to, I had went to these camps that I loved.
Like it was, I had a million things I was doing.
So, and I, it was just, it was smart because nothing ever really got me
就像是谁，这是怎么开始的？不，这其实挺棒的。不，我年轻时做过很多不同的事情。你知道，我的，我回去参加试镜。就像我说的，我去打网球。我去了，我去了那些我喜爱的夏令营。就像是，我有无数的事情在做。所以，而且，这很明智，因为没有什么真正能让我
down like I wasn't like a child actor who was just acting like I just it was another thing that I did
and then if that didn't I had a tennis lesson or I went away for the weekend like it they just
constantly had me in all these different things and until it got a little bit more serious and I remember
very clearly they sat me down it was pretty young I probably was not even eight or eight or nine
years old and they sat me down they're like you're this is a real job like do you want to
keep doing this and I there was like not a doubt in my mind I was like this is what I want to do
They're like, are you sure?
Yeah.
沮丧，我不是那种只懂得演戏的童星，我就觉得这只是我做的另一件事，如果这个不行，我还有网球课，或者我周末要出去玩，他们就是不断让我参与所有这些不同的事情，直到它变得稍微严肃一点，我非常清楚地记得他们把我拉坐下来，那时候我还很小，可能连八岁或八九岁都不到，他们让我坐下，说：“你，这是一份真正的工作，你想继续做下去吗？”我当时心里没有一丝怀疑，我说：“这就是我想做的事。”他们说：“你确定吗？”是的。
You're talking about tennis?
No, sorry.
I wanted to be an actor.
So keep playing tennis.
Keep doing both.
Have the second thing.
They weren't comfortable with me just doing the acting thing.
What was the first real gig?
你在说网球吗？不，抱歉。我想当演员。所以继续打网球。两样都做。留个备选。对于我只搞表演这件事，他们觉得不太自在。第一个真正的演出是什么？
Were the first real paying like Cheerios, something like that?
I mean, I did do all those commercials.
I was the Barbie girl for like two years.
I did like a handful of Barbie commercials.
I was in every single one.
Do you still have them on tape?
Oh, yeah, somewhere.
My mom does for sure.
第一个真正的商业演出是像Cheerios（雀巢麦圈）那样的广告吗？我是说，我确实拍了所有那些广告。我当了大约两年的芭比女孩。我拍了大概好几个芭比广告。每个广告里都有我。你现在还留着录像带吗？哦，对，在某个地方。我妈妈肯定留着。
I want to see those.
I was the Oscar Meyer.
sang the Oscar Meyer song.
Give us a little.
Yeah.
Well, I don't know how to spell anymore.
I wish I were an Oscar Meyer weener.
Exactly.
我想看看那些。我是奥斯卡·迈尔（Oscar Mayer）的。唱了奥斯卡·迈尔的歌。给我们来一小段。好吧，我不会再拼写了。我希望我是一根奥斯卡·迈尔的热狗。完全正确。
Yes.
You sang that in the commercial?
Yeah, I had to do the whole thing and play against a fake little weiner.
Anybody?
I was tossing that up for you, Will.
I know.
No, no, no.
是的。你在广告里唱过那个？是的，我必须完成整段表演，还要跟一个假的小热狗演对手戏。有人吗？有人吗？我刚刚抛出这个梗是为了你，威尔。我知道。不，不，不。
All right.
So then you're acting along and was there a thought, well, maybe I should go to college, too,
to have, make sure I have like a backup or something.
Did you go to college?
Hated school.
So that was the one thing.
I just was not grade school, seventh, eighth, into early.
I said, I asked my parents if I could get my GED and I was very clear.
好吧。然后你一直在演戏，当时有没有想过，也许我也应该去上大学，以便确保我有一个退路什么的？你上过大学吗？讨厌学校。所以那是唯一的一点。我只是不喜欢文法学校、七年级、八年级，一直到早期。我问我父母我能不能考个GED（高中同等学历证书），我当时态度非常明确。
I'm like, guys, this is not for me.
Like, I know my future is not going to be, I don't, I hated school.
I don't need trigonometry.
Yeah, exactly.
It wasn't for me.
Even when I had to do set school, like the devastation that I had to like leave set to go do school,
It just killed my soul.
Sure.
我对他们说：“伙计们，这不适合我。我知道我的未来不会是，我不，我讨厌学校。我不需要三角函数。”是的，完全正确。这不适合我。甚至当我去片场学校上课时，那种必须离开片场去上学的绝望感，简直扼杀了我的灵魂。确实。
So they let, they were like, I can't believe they listened to me.
It's kind of amazing.
They let me get my GED.
Well, Gary's very permissive.
He was like, go ahead.
That's always been the bump on him.
They were so cool about it.
Wait, I'm such an idiot.
所以他们放任，他们当时就像，我简直不敢相信他们听取了我的意见。这真是太神奇了。他们让我去考了GED。好吧，加里非常开明。他当时说：“去吧。”大家对他的评价一直都是这样。他们对此太酷了。等等，我真是个白痴。
Were your parents' actors too?
No.
No, they were not.
My mom stayed at home with us since the minute we were born.
Jay, how do you know their names, Gary?
I'm just, you know, doing bits.
You know, I get a little bit of research.
I know their names.
你的父母也是演员吗？不。不，他们不是。自从我们出生那一刻起，我妈妈就一直在家照顾我们。杰伊，你怎么知道他们的名字叫加里？我只是，你知道的，在抛梗。你知道的，我做了一点调查。我知道他们的名字。
I'm acting as if I know them.
It's funny.
Okay, okay, okay.
Gary was a realtor.
Gary was in residential real estate.
Oh.
Yes, good job.
Mostly in the Camarillo area.
我表现得好像我认识他们一样。这很有趣。好吧，好吧，好吧。加里是个房地产经纪人。加里从事住宅房地产行业。哦。是的，干得好。主要在卡马里奥（Camarillo）地区。
Yes.
Yes?
Wow.
These are guesses.
He was a paramedic firefighter actually for a very long time.
Wow.
Yeah, went into real estate and my mom stayed home.
I mean, my mom truly drove me all around.
是的。是吗？哇。这些都是猜测。他其实当了很长时间的消防员兼急救员。哇。是的，后来转行做房地产，我妈妈留在家里。我是说，我妈妈真的开车到处载我。
Like, that's all she did.
Brothers and sisters?
My sister, yeah, my sister's three years younger.
My sister, did the same thing or no?
She did.
She loved school, though.
She went to high school.
She was like a, you know, a little social butterfly.
就像，她只做了这个。有兄弟姐妹吗？我有姐姐，是的，我妹妹比我小三岁。我妹妹，也做这个吗，还是没有？她也做。不过她很喜欢学校。她上了高中。她就像一个，你知道的，小社交花蝴蝶。
But she's an actor, too.
She has an amazing voice.
She's incredible.
Yeah, she was on Mass.
No, not Mass Singer.
The voice.
Yeah.
Oh, wow.
但她也是个演员。她有一副惊人的嗓音。她太不可思议了。是的，她上过《蒙面歌王》。不，不是《蒙面歌王》。是《美国好声音》。对，哦，哇。
Really?
Got through a couple rounds.
Now, with Gary's history and medicine, do you know CPR?
What's funny is we just learned CPR because of this baby.
Right.
So we had these private CPR sessions, which, by the way, was terrified.
I don't know if you, they're showing you how to do like the CPR on the baby.
That was, I'm like, I'm never going to remember this, by the way.
真的吗？过了好几轮。好了，鉴于加里的医学背景，你懂心肺复苏术（CPR）吗？有趣的是，我们刚因为这个孩子而学会了CPR。没错。所以我们上了这些私人的CPR课程，顺便说一句，当时吓死我了。我不知道你们有没有，他们向你展示如何在婴儿身上做CPR。那简直，我心想，我永远也记不住这个，顺便说一句。
I'm so traumatized by even doing it on the fake baby.
So we did technically learn, but I learned it too, but I think I'm, I need a refresher
because I think I may have forgotten maybe because like you forget one little component.
It's useless.
It's crazy, right?
Sean Will, do you guys know CPR?
No.
I don't, but I can guess.
我甚至在假婴儿身上做练习都快被整出心理阴影了。所以我们从技术上来说确实学会了，我也学会了，但我认为我，我需要复习一下，因为我觉得我可能已经忘光了，因为如果你漏掉一个小环节。它就没用了。这太疯狂了，对吧？肖恩，威尔，你们懂CPR吗？不。我不懂，但我可以猜。
But wait, how to do it.
But wait.
In a pitch?
Yeah, in a pitch.
I could probably just guess what you do.
You just plug them.
You plug the nose.
make out with the person and then pound on the show.
但等等，怎么做。但等等。在紧急关头？是的，在紧急关头。我大概可以猜出你要做什么。你只是把它们塞住。你把鼻子堵上。跟那个人舌吻，然后捶打胸口。
Yeah, you're right.
It's a Saturday.
Yeah.
But wait, I always thought it was so crazy in like movies and TV shows when people, you know,
are passed out or whatever dying and people have to do CPR and they're pounding on their chest.
How does the actor not like moot?
Like I'd be like, ow, ow, ow, ow, every time.
You know what I mean?
对，你说得对。是个星期六。对。但等等，我一直觉得在电影和电视剧里，当人们，你知道的，晕倒或快死的时候，人们不得不做CPR并且猛击他们的胸口，这太疯狂了。演员怎么能不发出呕吐声呢？就像我会觉得，哦，哦，哦，每次都这样。你知道我的意思吗？
You're the worst actor.
God.
Well, I think they, I remember we had to do CPR in a scene in flight of time.
I mean, they're pretty padded.
I don't think we're just socking people in the chat.
Sean, do you want to just, this is like a question,
hey, we got a question from the audience over here for showbiz.
When you guys are shooting a movie, is it real?
你是最烂的演员。天哪。好吧，我想他们，我记得我们在《空乘危机》里的一场戏中必须做CPR。我是说，他们穿了很厚的垫子。我不认为我们真的在胸口猛击别人。肖恩，你想不想，这就好像是一个问题，嘿，我们这里有观众提出的一个关于演艺圈的问题。当你们拍电影时，那是真的吗？
What are you doing, dude?
I always wondered that.
I always wondered that because it looks like, you know, you're pounding.
And also when you're breathing,
when you're breathing into their mouth in a TV show or movie,
and how are you not going, like, you know, how do you like?
I went down to give you mouth to mouth on Murder Bill,
And you just, you, I thought you were going to let me and then you didn't.
你在干什么，老兄？我一直很好奇这个。我一直很好奇，因为看起来，你知道的，你在捶打。还有当你在呼吸时，当你在电视剧或电影中向他们口对口人工呼吸时，你怎么能不发出那种，你知道的，你怎么能不？我为了在《谋杀案》中给你做人工呼吸而俯身，
And then I was like, wait, you're going to let me and you didn't.
I was too embarrassed.
You guys, that was so good.
Jason, I had to give you.
Oh, no, I had to put a pill in your mouth.
You'd have put a pill in my mouth in the rest of the development.
And I kept telling you that I hadn't washed my hands.
But, but, uh...
而你只是，你，我以为你会让我亲结果你没有。然后我就想，等等，你本来要让我亲结果你没有。我太尴尬了。伙计们，那太精彩了。杰森，我得给你。哦，不，我得把一粒药放进你嘴里。你在戏里把一粒药放进我嘴里。我一直告诉你我没洗手。但是，但是……
This is about Kaylee.
I know, this is about Kaylee.
Wait, so they put pads on?
They put padding on. They put padding on the same.
Can we please escort this guy out of the other?
I know.
This is...
They put padding on and then you push it on.
这是关于凯莉的。我知道，这是关于凯莉的。等等，所以他们加了护垫？他们加了衬垫。他们在场景里加了衬垫。我们能不能请这位观众离开这里？我知道。这是……他们加了衬垫，然后你在上面按压？
the pad?
Yeah.
Oh, I didn't know that.
Yeah, and then they'll cut to, you know, his chest and they'll take the pad out.
Sean, you know, you know, Star Wars, you know, they don't shoot that in space, right?
Yeah.
And the lightsabers are not, they won't really cut you in half.
Hey, may the fourth be with you.
在垫子上？对。哦，我不知道那个。是的，然后他们会切到，你知道的，他的胸部特写，他们会把垫子拿掉。肖恩，你知道的，你知道《星球大战》，你知道，他们不是在太空中拍摄的，对吧？对。而且光剑也不是，它们不会真的把你劈成两半。嘿，愿原力与你同在。
God.
And we will be right back.
And now, back to the show.
Kaley, were you prepared for the Uber success of Big Bang?
Like, all the fame, the notoriety, the money.
everything changed and sort of exponentially every year.
Notoriety means something bad.
Notariety means it's bad.
天哪。我们马上回来。现在，回到节目中。凯莉，你对《生活大爆炸》取得的滔天成功做好准备了吗？比如，所有的名气、恶名、金钱。一切都变了，而且每年都呈指数级增长。恶名意味着不好的事情。恶名意味着那是坏事。
Didn't you shoot the pilot like a couple times or something?
Yes, I was actually the third actress to join Big Bang Theory.
Really?
Yes.
Wow.
They did, I believe, two pilots.
Old Chuck had the thinning shears out, huh?
100%.
你不是拍过好几次试播集还是什么的吗？是的，我其实是第三个加入《生活大爆炸》的女演员。真的吗？是的。哇。他们拍了，我相信，有两个试播集。老查克拿着打薄剪剪掉了，对吧？100%。
You're out.
Do you know who did it?
Do you know the people?
You don't have to say their names, but do you know the people who did it before you, the pilot?
I knew one of them.
Yeah.
Awkward, huh?
你出局了。你知道是谁拍的吗？你知道那些人是谁吗？你不用说出他们的名字，但你知道在你之前拍试播集的人是谁吗？我认识其中一个。是的。我认识其中一个。很尴尬吧？
Weird.
Well, yeah.
Well, I knew her later.
So it wasn't like she was my friend at the time.
I'm like, oh, you got a show and then I went and took it.
But no, I did know her later.
And she actually ended up guest starring.
She was still friends with everybody.
诡异。好吧，是的。好吧，我后来认识了她。所以当时她并不是我的朋友。我心想，哦，你接了一部剧，然后我去把它接手了。不过没有，我后来认识了她。而且她最后还来客串了。她和大家都还是朋友。
It was all fine.
Oh, good.
I know.
So they shot one pilot trashed it, two, second pilot trashed it.
I believe so.
And then the third pilot you were in the pilot.
Yes.
They kept rewriting it and revamping it.
一切都很好。哦，太好了。我知道。所以他们拍了一个试播集，扔了；第二个试播集，又扔了。我想是这样的。然后第三个试播集里有你。是的。他们一直在重写和翻新。
I mean, it was totally changed when I joined.
like it wasn't what it was.
And so what is it about, like this is fascinating to me,
what is it about that particular show
that they kept throwing money at it and redoing it?
And what was it that they believed in so much,
just the concept and the actors in it?
Or like, why, whereas that pose,
我是说，当我加入时，它完全变了。它已经不是原来的样子了。那么这到底是关于什么的，这让我很着迷，究竟是什么原因让那部特定的剧集不断砸钱重拍？究竟是什么让他们如此坚信不疑，仅仅是概念和里面的演员吗？或者说，为什么，与此相比，
as opposed to other shows,
you shoot a pilot, it didn't go, they throw it out.
Like, bye, right.
I think, I remember Chuck did a couple.
I know he's talked about this before,
but he just, like, really believed in it
and the studio believed in Chuck.
And he kept saying,
与其他剧集相反，你拍了一个试播集，没被采纳，他们就把它扔掉。比如，再见，对吧。我想，我记得查克拍了好几个。我知道他以前谈过这个，但他只是，非常相信它，而电视台也相信查克。他一直说，
give us another chance, give us another chance.
Like I can make, I think I'm going to make this work.
And, you know, he's Chuck and he does.
So they, they just kind of.
He's single-handedly kept sitcoms alive for the last...
100%.
Yeah.
But he kept saying, I'm going to get this right.
再给我们一次机会，再给我们一次机会。我觉得我能，我觉得我能把它做好。而且，你知道，他是查克，他做到了。所以他们，他们只是有点。他凭一己之力让情景喜剧在过去……100%。是的。但他一直说，我会把它做对的。
I'm going to get this right.
And, you know, he...
And so what about all the fame and the money and the, the,
being recognized on the street, all is it?
Like, were you prepared for all that?
Because it was, I mean, the show was enormous.
You know what's so crazy?
I feel like my sort of...
我会把它做对的。而且，你知道，他……那么所有这些名誉、金钱和，在街上被认出来，所有这些，是吗？就像，你对所有这一切都有所准备吗？因为它是，我是说，这部剧太庞大了。你知道最疯狂的是什么吗？我觉得我的那种……
I hated him in this word, whatever, this fame or whatever.
I was such on a slow, like, uphill climb.
I feel like there are actors who get, like, maybe they do, I don't know,
they do some huge film or something,
then all of a sudden, right, it's overnight fame,
and they're like, oh, my God.
I don't really feel like it was like that for me.
Like, I've been doing this since I was five years old.
我讨厌这个词，管它呢，这种名气什么的。我是在进行一种极其缓慢的、艰难的爬升。我觉得有些演员，可能他们拍了，我不知道，他们拍了一部巨大的电影或者什么的，然后突然之间，对吧，一夜成名，他们就会觉得，哦，天哪。我真的不觉得我经历过那种情况。我是说，我从五岁起就开始干这个了。
Right.
Like, not that I was famous back then,
but, like, I've always been in the business and I've always done a million things.
And it never affected me that, like, I never felt that much.
moment of, oh my God, I knew when Big Bang hit.
Because it was what you did for a living.
Yeah, but Big Bang Theory got like 30 million viewers a week.
Like, it was insane.
对。就像，倒不是说我那时候就很出名，而是，我一直都在这个行业里，我一直都在做无数的事情。这从未对我的生活产生影响，以至于，我从没有过那种巨大的时刻，哦天哪，我知道《生活大爆炸》火了。因为那是你谋生的手段。是的，但是《生活大爆炸》每周有大约3000万观众。这太疯狂了。
I know.
I mean, it was awesome.
We were thrilled.
Sean and I did, when we did that show, The Millers,
and especially the first season, we were on behind you guys,
behind Big Bang Theory for a year.
And you single-handedly, like, kept us on the air because we had the lead in of Big
Bank Theory.
我知道。我是说，这太棒了。我们当时欣喜若狂。肖恩和我，当我们拍那部剧《米勒一家》时，特别是第一季，我们在你们后面播出，在《生活大爆炸》后面播了一年。你们凭一己之力，就像，把我们留在了荧屏上，因为我们有《生活大爆炸》作为前导剧。
We were like, sweet.
We could just air some dial tone.
if we wanted.
But then you can't drop off a lot, right?
Then you got the pressure of trying to hold that number.
We did drop off.
Yeah, and then they got,
and then they moved us,
我们当时想，太棒了。如果我们愿意，我们甚至可以只播放一些拨号音。但随后你不能掉收视率太多，对吧？然后你就有保持住那个数字的压力。我们确实掉了。是的，然后他们得到了，然后他们把我们移开，
and then we were like,
oh, we're screwed.
But it was a little phenomenon, man.
I don't know.
It was just massive.
And I know, you know who I know,
I knew a few people,
but I certainly know Johnny a little bit,
然后我们就想，哦，我们完蛋了。但那真是一个小小的现象级作品，老天。我不知道。它就是太庞大了。而且我知道，你知道我认识谁，我确实认识几个人，但我绝对了解一点约翰尼，
such a nice guy.
Of course.
Oh, he's the greatest.
He's the best.
He's such a nice guy.
Such a nice soul.
He's like doing his thing now.
Yeah, where did he move to?
人太好了。当然。哦，他是最棒的。他是最好的。他是个如此好的人。如此美好的灵魂。他现在在过他自己的生活。是的，他搬到哪里去了？
Did he move to, like, Tennessee or something?
Nashville, loving it.
Yeah.
That's so great.
He's such a good guy.
I got to tell him.
I saw you talk to you guys.
Yeah, please say how to inform me.
他是搬到，比如田纳西州还是什么地方？纳什维尔，他很喜欢那里。太棒了。他真是个好人。我得告诉他。我看到你和你们说话了。是的，请代我问好。
I totally.
He's just a sweet person.
I know.
All right.
So now what you've done is you've somewhat combined your passion for acting and your passion for tennis.
Although you're letting Chris Messina do the tennis part.
But tell us about this incredible new show called Based on a True Story.
我绝对会的。他就是个很甜美的人。我知道。我知道。好吧。所以现在你所做的，在某种程度上结合了你对表演的热情和你对网球的热情。尽管你让克里斯·梅西纳（Chris Messina）去打网球。但跟我们讲讲这部名为《基于真实故事》的不可思议的新剧吧。
That produced by aggregate.
Do you know that you probably know this?
But when I met Mr. Tom Palfrey, he had this script in his hand.
He was reading.
it like three weeks into dating him and I go what do you read and he goes I'm reading this based on a
true story I can't do it because I didn't know that yes and I don't think I know that read it and I was
like give me that let me read it he goes it's so funny this is obviously a year ago yeah and I go
oh my god this is hilarious he goes I know it's so funny it's Jason's Jason doing it and all this
由Aggregate制作。你知道吗，你可能知道这个？但当我遇到汤姆·佩尔福瑞（Tom Palfrey）先生时，他手里拿着这个剧本。我们在约会大约三周后，他正在读它，我问：“你在读什么？”他说：“我在读这个《基于真实故事》，我演不了，因为我不知道”是的，我想我当时不知道，读一下，然后我说：“把那个给我，让我读读。”他说：“这太有趣了，这显然是一年前的事了。”是的，我说：“哦，天哪，这太搞笑了吧。”他说：“我知道，太有趣了。这是杰森的，杰森在弄这个，诸如此类。”我从杰森的房车里偷来的。我不能，他永远不会读它，他永远不会抽出时间重读它。
stuff I stole it from Jason's trailer I can't he'll never read it he'll never get around to
rehing it. Well, he was going to play the plumber.
He was looking at him maybe playing the plumber.
After working with him on Ozark, like anything and everything I heard about or thought about,
you know, and people were talking to me about him.
It's like, yeah, what about Tom for this?
What about Tom for that?
He loves you so much, man.
嗯，他本来要演那个水管工。他当时在考虑让他也许演那个水管工。在《黑钱胜地》和他合作之后，我听到或想到的一切，你知道的，人们都在跟我谈论他。就像是，“是的，汤姆演这个怎么样？汤姆演那个怎么样？”他太爱你了吧，老兄。
Chances are high that maybe that was something I was aware of, but it was one of many.
Probably had a bunch of stuff.
Isn't that crazy that I was like, let me see that.
And I like, went through it.
I said, this is brilliant.
Obviously, that was months before I even ever got to call for it.
and things were written very differently.
The couple had older kids.
很有可能我当时对此有所了解，但这也只是其中之一。可能有一堆东西。难道不疯狂吗，我当时说：“让我看看那个。”然后我，翻了翻。我说：“这太天才了。”很显然，那是几个月前，甚至在我接到试镜电话之前，而且剧本写得和现在非常不同。那对夫妇有更大的孩子。
The story was a little bit different.
So once I got the call and I was kind of talking about it with you guys,
I was like, I love this so much.
But I don't know if I would have teenagers.
Like we started talking and then Craig, our showrunner was like,
we'll take away the kids.
Like they were kind of helping me figure out how this could be.
I loved it so much.
故事稍微有些不同。所以一旦我接到电话，我开始和你们讨论它时，我心想：“我太喜欢这个了。但我不知道我能不能演有十几岁孩子的母亲。”我们开始讨论，然后克雷格，我们的运作人就说：“我们把孩子拿掉吧。”就像他们一直在帮我弄清楚这该怎么运作。我太喜欢了。
Plus, I love true crime.
I love tennis.
I love working in L.A.
I was like, I need all these things.
This is great.
So the general concept of it.
Good job.
Yeah.
另外，我喜欢真实罪案。我喜欢网球。我喜欢在洛杉矶工作。我当时想：我需要所有这些元素。这太棒了。所以它的总体概念是。干得好。是的。
So the general concept is that you and Christmasona are married, the great Christmasina.
The best.
We'll hold for applause there.
He plays an ex-teness star.
You play a realtor that is obsessed with true crime podcasts.
You have a plumber come to the house to fix a toilet played by, ironically, Tom Bateman.
Yes, fabulous.
所以总体概念是，你和克里斯·梅西纳结婚了，伟大的克里斯·梅西纳。最棒的。我们在这里暂停一下等待掌声。最棒的。他饰演一个前网球明星。你饰演一个痴迷于真实罪案播客的房地产经纪人。你们家来了一个水管工修马桶，讽刺的是，这个角色由汤姆·巴特曼（Tom Bateman）饰演。是的，棒极了。
Isn't that weird?
Yes.
And this guy turns out to maybe be a serial killer
and you guys decide, well, we're not going to turn him in
if he agrees to do a podcast with us about his serial killing.
I got to see that.
And we'll keep his name away from the authorities.
That's great.
难道不诡异吗？是的。而这个家伙后来可能是一个连环杀手，然后你们决定，好吧，如果我们不把他交给当局，前提是他同意和我们一起做一个关于他连环杀人案的播客。我得去看看那个。我们就把他的名字对当局保密。这太棒了。
There's probably a better way to describe it, but that's the bones of it, right?
That sounds great.
Wait, when is this on?
This is coming June 8th.
June 8th on the peacock.
Absolutely.
What, this is streaming on the cock?
It's streaming out of the cock.
可能有一种更好的方式来描述它，但这正是它的核心骨架，对吧？听起来很棒。等等，这个什么时候播？这是6月8日上映。6月8日在Peacock播出。绝对的。什么，这个在那个什么上流媒体播放？在那个什么上流媒体播放。
Of course.
Yeah.
That's what we always say on the, anything for a...
Wait, but that sounds really great.
Yeah, I know.
It does sound really good.
It was such a quirky.
当然。是的。是的。我们在，为了……等等，但听起来真的很棒。是的，我知道。听起来确实很好。这是一个非常古怪的。
It was so insane the story.
I thought it was so brilliant.
I said, I have to be part of this.
And then, like, after we had, I had signed on,
we got everything going, I came to L.A.
to do some chemistry reads.
And Jason wasn't there, but there was, the producers were there,
and I was talking to everyone.
这个故事太疯狂了。我觉得太天才了。我说：“我必须成为其中的一部分。”然后，就像在我们，我签约之后，我们一切都走上正轨后，我来到洛杉矶进行一些化学反应试读。杰森不在那儿，但制片人在，我在和每个人聊天。
And I sat them down and like, guys,
because they had written it,
and it was done and ready to go.
I was like, guys, what if this character was pregnant?
Just fitball.
And Craig goes, I'm like, now think, think hard about this.
Think about your answer first.
Yeah, really think hard because this could really be in there like, well, I'm like, no, really.
我让他们坐下来，就像，“伙计们，因为他们已经写好了剧本，而且已经完成准备开拍了。”我说：“伙计们，如果这个角色怀孕了会怎么样？”只是随便抛出一个想法。克雷格说，我说：“现在想想，认真考虑一下这个。先想想你的回答。”是的，真的好好想想，因为这真的可以写进去，像，我说，不，真的。
And they're looking at me and they're like, what?
I'm like, surprise.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
We were like a month out from shooting, maybe a little longer.
But I said, do you think you could write it in?
And how many months were you?
他们看着我，就像，什么？我说：惊喜。是的。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。我们离开拍大概有一个月，可能稍微久一点。但我说：“你觉得你们能把它写进去吗？”你当时几个月了？
When we started shooting, I was five months.
I mean, we shot three weeks before I gave birth.
Wow.
About up until three weeks before I gave birth.
Yeah, so I was five months when we started.
So let's say I was like four.
And didn't they say, well, well, Kaylee, we can delay start a production.
Like have your kid enjoy it.
我们开始拍摄时，我五个月了。我是说，我们拍到我生孩子前三周才停。哇。直到我生孩子前三周都在拍。是的，所以我们开始时我五个月。所以可以说我当时大概四个月。他们难道没有说：“哦，凯莉，我们可以推迟开拍。让你的孩子享受这个。”
And you were like, no, no, no, no.
No.
Right?
I want to do it now.
Because I also, not only did I want to do the show and I was so ready to do it,
I actually not be, and also I wanted to, for them to write in their
pregnancy, I actually thought it worked for the show.
And once we all talked it out, it actually worked.
而你却说：“不，不，不，不。”不。对吧？我想现在就拍。因为我也，不仅我想拍这部剧，而且我完全准备好了去拍，我实际上不想，而且我也希望他们把怀孕写进剧里，我其实觉得这很适合这部剧。一旦我们讨论清楚了，这真的行得通。
I don't remember it not being about this couple being pregnant.
Plus, the way they wrote it in was so brilliant.
Like, it never focused on the pregnancy.
It just was, I was just pregnant.
Also, up's the jeopardy, too, that you're basically working with the serial killer
and you can see this big huge baby bump the whole way through.
Yeah.
Bonasas.
我不记得这部剧不是关于这对怀孕夫妇的了。另外，他们把它写进去的方式太天才了。就像，它从未聚焦于怀孕本身。它只是，我就是怀孕了。而且，这也增加了危险性，基本上你是在和一个连环杀手合作，而你整个过程中都能看到这个巨大的孕肚。是的。太棒了。
That's cool.
So you were five months pregnant and through till what being eight months pregnant by the time
we wrapped?
Four weeks before I gave birth, it was.
my rap day. Yeah. But it was awesome because I got to, I mean, what job I got to eat what I wanted.
I was treated like a freaking queen. It was the best. I wore what I wanted. I was felt very empowered.
And also like, I've been in this business for so long. Yes, comfy shoes. I've been able to like play
my eight. I've been in this business for so long that I thought it was cool. Like, okay, now people are
这太酷了。所以你从怀孕五个月一直拍到我们杀青时怀孕八个月？在我杀青那天，离我生孩子还有四周。是的。但太棒了，因为我得到了，我是说，这是一份什么工作啊，我想吃什么就吃什么。我被当成女王一样对待。这太棒了。我想穿什么就穿什么。我感到非常有力量。而且就像，我在这个行业呆了这么久。是的，舒服的鞋子。我能够像扮演我的角色。我在这个行业呆了太久，以至于我觉得这很酷。就像，好吧，现在人们
seeing me like, I'm going to be real about this and I'm going to show that this is exactly what I am.
and I'm pregnant and it's fine and I'm working
and I thought it was like a good thing to do.
I don't know. It just felt right.
That's cool.
I would have killed to play that killer.
I wouldn't play a killer.
He's great.
看到我这样，我要对此保持真实，我要展现出这就是真实的我，我怀孕了，这很好，我在工作，我觉得这是一件很好的事。我不知道。感觉就是对的。这太酷了。我宁愿死也要演那个杀手。我才不想演杀手。他演得很棒。
He's really great.
He is great.
I can't wait to see it.
They're all great.
It's really cool, weird show and very funny.
Now, you're very lucky because it's shot in Los Angeles.
You're going to be able to bring Matilda to the set
if and when there's a second season.
他真的很棒。他太棒了。我迫不及待想看了。他们都很棒。这真是一部酷炫、古怪且非常有趣的剧。现在，你非常幸运，因为它是在洛杉矶拍摄的。如果第二季有的话，你将能够把玛蒂尔达带到片场。
Yes.
Have you thought about how that's all going to kind of play out?
I mean...
Dude, I would do a second season in a heartbeat.
I know. Let's get it done. Let's get this done today.
It was one of the most fun experiences I have ever. I really mean that.
That Christmas scene is just a real joy.
We laughed.
是的。你想过这一切会如何发展吗？我是说……老兄，我恨不得马上就拍第二季。我知道。我们把它搞定吧。我们今天就把这事定了。这是我经历过最有趣的体验之一。我是说真的。那个圣诞场景简直是一场纯粹的欢乐。我们笑个不停。
And that's what's fun.
Not to, we move on after this, but that is real.
I mean, the writing is fantastic.
Concepts fun and all that stuff.
But the chemistry between you two guys, I don't know.
It's just, I do stuff sometimes and people say, hey, boy, how did you guys get such great chemistry?
Well, it's, when you have two really nice people, it's pretty simple.
Thanks, man.
这才是好玩的地方。不是说要翻过这一篇，但那是真的。我是说，剧本棒极了。概念很有趣诸如此类的。但你们两个之间的化学反应，我不知道。有时候我做某些事，人们会说：“嘿，伙计，你们是怎么产生这么好的化学反应的？”好吧，很简单，当你和两个真正好的人合作时，这其实挺简单的。谢谢，老兄。
Chris, or Sean Will, don't you guys agree?
Like, chemistry is not a mystery if you're not working with a dickhead.
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
It's simple.
Chris is just awesome.
People are like, well, they had great chemistry.
Yeah, because they're normal, nice people.
Yeah, exactly.
克里斯，或者肖恩、威尔，你们不觉得吗？化学反应并不是什么神秘的东西，只要你不是和一个混蛋合作。是的，是的，完全正确。很简单。克里斯就是太棒了。人们会说：“哦，他们的化学反应太棒了。”是的，因为他们是正常、好心的人。是的，完全正确。
It's good.
Right.
And it's infectious, and it works for the characters, too,
because you guys are kind of awshucksing while working with a serial killer.
It's pretty great.
No, we had a blast, man.
It was awesome.
I can't even tell you.
这很好。对。而且它具有感染力，这对角色也很有用，因为你们一边和连环杀手合作，一边表现得大惊小怪。这真的很棒。不，我们玩得很开心，老兄。太棒了。我甚至无法形容。
I had a question about, well, I just want to say it out loud.
It's what's it called again?
Based on a true story
June 8th streaming on the cock
Just so we can say it
Just so I can because neither of you can say it
But I can say it
You know
我有一个问题，好吧，我只想大声说出来。这叫什么来着？《基于真实故事》，6月8日在Peacock播出。只是为了让我们说出来。只是为了我可以，因为你们两个都说不出口，但我可以说。你知道
I can see it
Set his calendar
You're ready to do it
Are we having a viewing party
At your housewell?
We're gonna do a viewing
We're doing it
Are you kidding?
我能看到。把日程定好。你准备好去做了吗？我们要在你家办观影派对吗，威尔？我们要办一场观影会。我们在办。你在开玩笑吗？
Are you fucking
Do you fucking?
Would you, I want to know
I have something
Go ahead Sean
Do you have like
Do you have any kind of desire
你在开玩笑吗？你在他妈的，你他妈的？你会不会，我想知道，我有件事。说吧，肖恩。你有没有那种，任何形式的渴望？
To write and to be a writer
And to write scripts
And like direct
Not even a little bit
A little bit.
I think I could direct.
I think I would be a good director because I like to get in and get out.
Like I don't waste a lot of time.
去写作，当一名作家，写剧本，然后像去导演？一点也没有。有一点点。我觉得我可以导演。我觉得我会是一个好导演，因为我喜欢雷厉风行。我不喜欢浪费太多时间。
I'm also not every, like it was funny working with Messino who is very,
likes to prepare and likes to rehearse and watch every, you know, playback.
I, that is not my jam at all.
You're in your own.
Yeah, I would like to get in there.
Why are we talking about this?
Let's just shoot it.
And then Chris is like, but we have to, what are we going to do now?
我也不是所有人，就像和梅西纳合作很有趣，他非常，喜欢准备，喜欢排练并观看每一个，你知道的，回放。我，那可完全不是我的菜。你在你自己的节奏里。对，我只想直接开拍。我们为什么在谈这个？直接拍就行了。然后克里斯就会说：“但是我们必须，我们现在该怎么办？”
Like he's hysterical.
So the two of us together kind of balanced.
That was like me with Laura Linney.
Laura was very, very prepared,
very sort of always the notes and the script
and the lines always learned.
And like it was very admirable.
But I just, my brain doesn't work like that.
就像他情绪激动。所以我们俩在一起算是一种平衡。这就好像我和劳拉·琳妮（Laura Linney）在一起。劳拉非常非常注重准备，非常习惯总是带着笔记、剧本和背熟的台词。而且这非常令人钦佩。但我的大脑就是不那样运转。
Me too. Very admirable.
I mean, my brain does not work that way either.
It's just not for me.
I know.
But it makes a great partnership.
Yeah, I'm not a playback watcher.
As an actor, I can't watch playback.
So Tracy, what happens here is that you shoot a scene
我也是。非常令人钦佩。我是说，我的大脑也不是那样运转的。这真的不适合我。我知道。但这构成了伟大的合作关系。是的，我不看回放。作为演员，我无法看回放。所以崔西，这里发生的情况是，你拍完一场戏，
and then you can go to the monitor.
or a little TV next to where you just shot,
and they'll play it back for you so you can see what you did good,
what you did bad, what the technical things are
you need to look out for.
Then you go and you shoot it again.
And it really was initially, it's not for the actors,
it's generally for the director,
然后你可以走到监视器前。或者走到你刚拍完的场景旁边的小电视前，他们会把回放给你看，这样你可以看到你哪里演得好，哪里演得不好，有哪些需要注意的技术问题。然后你再去重拍一遍。而且这实际上最初并不是给演员看的，通常是给导演看的，
so the director can watch, maybe the producers.
See what the camera is seeing.
Yeah, see what the camera's seeing.
And it'd be like, hey, let's get that again.
Maybe there's a bump on the camera move.
Maybe the light wasn't right, maybe the wrong line, whatever.
By the way, you know who invented or created the playback?
Who's that show?
这样导演可以观察，也许还有制片人。看看摄像机看到了什么。是的，看看摄像机看到了什么。然后就会说：“嘿，我们再拍一次。”也许摄像机移动时有个颠簸。也许光线不对，也许台词说错了，诸如此类。顺便问一句，你知道是谁发明或创造了回放吗？那是谁，演出？
Jerry Lewis.
Is that right?
Really?
What?
Huh.
Now, some actors will not look at playback.
And they won't even see the film once it's all done, cut together.
杰瑞·刘易斯（Jerry Lewis）。是吗？真的吗？什么？哈。哈。现在，有些演员不看回放。他们甚至在全部完成、剪辑好之后都不去看这部电影。
And I don't get that.
I learned so much about what I did wrong by looking at what I do.
Like watching the end product.
Yeah, it's like shoot it and go home and then go to the next job.
That's me, too.
Otherwise, you're just obsessed.
You obsess about, like, you know, I can't do it.
I'm the same way.
而我无法理解这一点。我通过看自己做的事学到了很多关于我做错了什么。就像看最终的产品。是的，就像拍完就回家，然后去下一个工作。我也是这样。否则你就会陷入痴迷。你会痴迷于，你知道的，我做不到。我也是这样。
Maybe I should do that with golf will.
Maybe I should care a little bit less.
Well, let me just tell you, I was going to be.
going to say to you, I talked about you at great length
with Josh last night. Oh, boy.
This is true. And I did bring up that you're not,
you know Josh. Oh, Josh. He's a friend of ours
that we play golf with. And so Josh,
也许我应该用高尔夫来对付威尔。也许我应该稍微少操点心。好吧，我来告诉你，我本来想对你说的，我昨晚和乔希（Josh）长篇大论地谈论过你。哦，天哪。这是真的。我确实提到了你不是，你知道乔希。哦，乔希。他是我们的朋友，我们一起打高尔夫。所以乔希，
who's, he's a, Kaley, he's a friend
of ours, he's a bald fella, and I keep saying that I want him to
start wearing a different wig every day. And I said, it'd be
amazing. Because he keeps his head shaved,
and I'm like, if he showed up every day
with a different wig. Oh, my
God, I never, that is
so fun. So,
他是个，凯莉，他是我们的朋友，他是个秃顶的家伙，我一直说我想让他每天戴一顶不同的假发。我说，那太棒了。因为他一直光着头，我说，如果他每天戴着一顶不同的假发出现。哦，天哪，我从来没有，那太有趣了。所以，
anyway, we were saying, apart
for the fact that Jason, I think you're malnourished and your blood sugar is abnormally low
and that that's what makes you cranky all the time in everything you do, not just golf.
I think on top of that, you need to stand over the ball and hit it.
And you have too many thoughts.
And Jason is known as one of the slower golfers in the Los Angeles Angeles.
I was so slow yesterday.
It was so slow yesterday.
不管怎样，我们刚才在说，除了杰森，我觉得你营养不良，血糖异常低，这才是让你做任何事都脾气暴躁的原因，不只是打高尔夫。我觉得除此之外，你需要站在球前把它击出去。而且你的想法太多了。杰森可是洛杉矶打高尔夫最慢的人之一。我昨天打得太慢了。昨天真的太慢了。
And he thinks about way too much.
And Kail, you know, as an actual, you know, competitive athlete that sometimes you just have to let it,
Your instincts take over.
You just got to go.
Yeah.
Maybe Kaylee needs to be the person to come play with you and walk with you
and be your kind of sport psychologist.
Yeah, be my whisper.
而且他想得太多了。凯莉，你知道的，作为一个真正的、你知道的竞技运动员，有时候你只需要放手，让你的直觉接管。你只需要直接打。是的。也许凯莉需要成为那个陪你打球、陪你散步、当你的运动心理学家的人。是的，做我的耳语者。
I would be so bad at golf.
That sport would make me insane.
Like, it would make me insane.
But you could talk him through.
You can be like, Jay, speed it up.
Hit it, hit the ball.
What about bowling?
Do you guys like to bowl?
我打高尔夫肯定极烂。这项运动会让我发疯的。真的会让我发疯。但你可以开导他。你可以说，杰，快一点。击球，打那个球。保龄球怎么样？你们喜欢打保龄球吗？
All right, Kaylee, this has been great.
Yeah, thank you for joining us today.
Sorry, unfortunately, somebody decided to.
capsized the whole thing with something bullshit about bowling.
That's a Tony Award-nominated actor.
Well, you said Josh's a ball guy, and I'm a ball guy.
And then you went to bowling.
And I went to bowling, and I liked to bowl.
好了，凯莉，这太棒了。是的，谢谢你今天加入我们。抱歉，不幸的是，有人用关于保龄球的废话把整场访谈给搅黄了。那可是托尼奖提名的演员。好吧，你说了乔希是个球类达人，而我个球类达人。然后你就扯到了保龄球。我扯到了保龄球，而且我喜欢打保龄球。
Antoinette Perry just rolled over.
Kaylee, I love you.
Thank you.
Love you, too.
You crushed this.
I'll see you again.
Thank you.
安托瓦内特·佩里刚刚气得在坟墓里打滚了。凯莉，我爱你。谢谢。我也爱你。你表现得太棒了。回头见。你表现得太棒了。谢谢。
You guys are a delight.
Thank you.
You got real good, chef.
on your girl. If I was a girl, I'd wear a scrunchy my hair like you do right now.
What do you think of the scrunchy?
I always do, this is my bit I always do with scrunch because old school I always go like,
listen guys, the thing is that I think that what we need to, and I always do my scrunch.
I always do my scrunchy bed.
你们真是太逗了。谢谢。你装得还挺像个女孩的。如果我是个女孩，我也会像你现在这样在头发上扎个大肠发圈。你觉得大肠发圈怎么样？我一直都这样，这是我经常用大肠发圈开的玩笑，因为老派嘛，我总是会说，听着伙计们，问题在于我认为我们需要的，然后我就会弄我的大肠发圈。我总是会表演我的大肠发圈梗。
I've never seen the scrunchy bit, Will.
Oh, I've seen the scrunchy bit for 20 years.
Yeah, guys, I think the problem is, look, if we go over there, can we, and I
Listener, he's gathering his hair.
He's gathering his hair and putting a faux fake scrunchy in his hair.
It's my favorite.
I love his scratch.
Because I have a big 80s scrunchy in my hair.
我从来没见过这个大肠发圈梗，威尔。哦，我看了二十年大肠发圈梗了。对啊，伙计们，我觉得问题在于，听着，如果我们去那边，我们能，和听众朋友们，他在收集头发。他在收集头发，往头上戴一个假的塑料大肠发圈。这是我的最爱。我喜欢他的发圈。因为我头发上有一个80年代风格的大磁带发圈。
I love it.
You guys are awesome.
Thank you for having it.
Thank you.
We love you.
You're the best.
You guys are amazing.
我喜欢。我太喜欢了。你们太棒了。谢谢你们来。谢谢。我们爱你们。你们是最棒的。你们太了不起了。
Thank you.
Have a great rest of the day.
Bye, guys.
Bye, Kaylee.
Thank you.
Bye.
Bye, bye, bye, bye.
谢谢。祝你们余下的一天过得愉快。再见，伙计们。再见，凯莉。谢谢。再见。再见。再见，再见，再见，再见。
Bye, bye, bye.
You guys, that's just, she's just, that's a real spirit.
She's got a great vibe, huh?
I said sunshine wrapped in skin, but maybe it's spirit wrapped in skin, huh?
And some sunshine.
She's one of those personalities, too, that's like a phenomenal actress,
but you can tell is a fun person and doesn't take life serious,
like she does her work serious, too.
拜拜，拜拜。伙计们，她真是，她身上有一种真正的精神。她很有活力，对吧？我说过她是阳光化身，但也许是精神化身，对吧？还带点阳光。她就是那种性格的人，不仅是个了不起的演员，而且你能看出她是个有趣的人，对生活并不像对工作那样严肃。
Kaylee was, you know, I've often touched...
Bubbly Cuoco.
Sorry?
That sounds like a great beverage on ice.
But Kaylee, but Kaylee, but it, she was so great on Big Bang theory.
and so funny and fun.
Yeah, just like a...
Yeah, she's had so much life to her.
凯莉曾经，你知道，我经常感动于……充满活力的库柯。抱歉？听起来像是一款加冰的绝佳饮品。但是凯莉，但是凯莉，但是，她在《生活大爆炸》里表现得太棒了。又搞笑又有趣。是的，就像一个……是的，她身上有那么多的生命力。
And then you think like, well, maybe that's sort of the character.
She's playing, nope, she is that person.
She has great energy, great vibe.
Yeah, all the time.
You want to hang out with her immediately.
You know, by the way, have you ever exited a plane
when the flight attendant, when you're leaving?
Oh, no.
然后你会想，也许那只是个角色。她演出来的，不，她就是那样的人。她能量满满，活力十足。是的，随时都这样。你会想立刻跟她一起出去玩。对了，你们有没有过这样的经历，当飞机降落，你正要离开时，空乘人员在……哦，不。
Too early.
It is too early, but go ahead.
Yeah, go ahead.
He says...
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday
to you
太早了。现在确实太早了，但你继续。是的，你继续。他说……祝你生日快乐。祝你生日快乐。祝你生日快乐。
Sweet
Willie Arnett
Happy
birthday
To you
Bye
Silky
That's a good one
亲爱的威利·阿奈特。祝你生日快乐。再见，西尔基。这个不错。
Smart
Smartless is
100%
organic and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjurf.
Smart. Bless.
Smartless 是由贝内特·巴尔比科、迈克尔·格兰特·特里和罗布·阿姆茹夫 100% 有机手工打造的。Smartless。